SENATOR -- PRODUCTS THAT ARE
LABOR COMMITTEE BILL AB TWO OH
FIVE WHICH MAKES TECHNICAL
CHANGES THE DEFINITION OF
SERIOUS INJURY ILLNESS AND
VIOLATIONS OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY
PROVISIONS THE LABOR CODE.
THESE TECHNOLOGIES OF A LANGUAGE
ONLINE WITH FEDERAL OSHA
STANDARDS AND CREATE UNIFORMITY
IN THE LABOR CODE.
THESE CHANGES ARE NEEDED BECAUSE
IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN FEDERAL
OSHA AMENDED IS REPORTING
REGULATION TO CHANGE THE TYPE OF
WORK RELATED INJURIES ON PLAYERS
MUST REPORT.
COVERED EMPLOYERS MUST REPORT
ALL WORK RELATED FATALITIES
HOSPITALIZATIONS OF ONE OR MORE
EMPLOYEES AS WELL AS ANY
AMPUTATION Là SOMETIME.
ANY STATE WITH ITS OWN OSHA
PLANTS JUST CALIFORNIA MUST MAKE
THE NECESSARY CHANGES TO CONFORM
TO THE FEDERAL OSHA REPORTING
REGULATION.
IN ADDITION IN TWO THOUSAND TEN
THE LEGISLATURE ENACTED AB
TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTY FOUR WHICH
MENTALLY BECAUSE SECTION SIXTY
FOUR THIRTY TWO TO CHANGE LEGAL
CENTER FOR CLASSIFYING A
VIOLATION AS SERIOUS.
THE PASSAGE OF AB TWO AND TWENTY
SEVEN SEVENTY FOUR CREATE
INCONSISTENCIES LABOR CODE
BECAUSE A BILL TO AMEND ALL THE
SECTIONS OR LEAD TO SERIOUS
VIOLATIONS STANDARD.
TECHNO CHANGES IN THIS BILL
CORRECT THESE INCONSISTENCIES
INCREASED UNIFORMITY AND LABOR
COVER THAT ARE RESPECT YES RIGHT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
STAGGER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL.
IN ADDITION TO THE IMPORTANT
TECHNICAL CHANGES MENTIONED BY
SOME MEMBER KALRA THE BILL ALSO
WE THINK GREATLY CLARIFIES THE
STANDARD THAT GOVERNS WHEN
EMPLOYERS AND FIRST RESPONDERS
DO HAVE.
TO REPORT SERIOUS INJURIES AND
FATALITIES TO CALIFORNIA -- WE
DO HAVE A PRETTY SERIOUS PROBLEM
WITH UNDER REPORTING THESE
INCIDENTS WHERE.
BY OUR BEST ESTIMATES ONLY ABOUT
HALF OF THE EXISTING FINALITY IS
IN SERIOUS INJURIES ARE REPORTED
TO CALIFORNIA -- DESPITE THE
FACT THERE'S A FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLAR PENALTY FOR DOING SO AND
ONE OF THE MAIN REASONS EXCUSE
ME THE UNDER REPORTING IS AN
ISSUE IS BECAUSE IT OFTEN
TRIGGERS AN INSPECTION.
AND SO THAT INSPECTION IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT SO THE
CALLOUS OR CAN GET OUT THERE IN
A TIMELY FASHION -- IF NECESSARY
AND ASSESS THE HAZARD TO MAKE
SURE THAT OTHER FATALITIES AND
OTHER SERIOUS INJURIES ARE A
RISK -- AND SO WE THINK THAT
THIS CHANGE OFFERED BY EIGHTEEN
OH FIVE MAKES IT MORE CLEAR FOR
EMPLOYERS TO KNOW WHEN THEY DO
NEED TO REPORT THESE THINGS AS
EXISTING STANDARD OF
HOSPITALIZATION FOR AT LEAST
TWENTY FOUR HOURS -- WE'VE HEARD
LOTS OF COMPLAINTS ABOUT THAT
STANDARD OVER THE YEARS AND
AGREE IT CAN SOMETIMES BE KIND
OF TOUGH FOR EMPLOYERS TO ASSESS
WHEN THEY ARE SUPPORTS TO REPORT
WITHOUT IN THE LAW.
BUT CHANGING IT TO JUST
HOSPITALIZATION SHOULD MAKE IT
MUCH MORE CLEAR AND SOMETHING
THAT OUR IS MORE CLEAR FOR
CALLUSES WELL IN DETERMINING
WHICH HAZARDS.
ARE ONES THAT THEY SHOULD EXPECT
AND WHICH ONES THEY ARE WE ARE
TONIGHT WITH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF OTHERS IN
SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANYONE HERE IN
OPPOSITION.
NO ONE BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE AND I WANT TO THANK
THE VICE CHAIR.
FOR INDULGING ME IN THIS
COMMITTEE AS I WAS PRESENTED TO
BILLS THIS MORNING OR HE SAID.
THANK YOU.
SEE NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK THANK YOU MISTER VICE
CHAIR RESPECTFULLY ASK RELIABLE
URBAN -- A QUORUM IS BEST VERY
GOOD THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE WILL --
TO TAKE UP THE MATTER AS SOON AS
A QUORUM IS PRESENT THANK YOU
[inaudible]
WE WILL.
NO MOVE TO ITEM NUMBER.
ONE AND GOOD MORNING
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GONZALEZ WHO CAN --
IT DID WANT TO ANNOUNCE THAT --
A. B. I REMEMBER TWELVE A. B..
FOURTEEN FIFTY NINE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER ARAMBULA BILA HAS
BEEN PULLED FROM TODAY'S HEARING.
IT WILL NOW GO TO ITEM NUMBER
ONE EIGHTY FIFTY ONE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GONZALES GOOD
MORNING AGAIN.
CAN I DO AND A TEN TWENTY EIGHT
FOR CERTAINLY MADE TO THINK.
TEN TWENTY EIGHT I REMEMBER NINE
A. B. TEN TWENTY EIGHT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS I'D LIKE
TO START BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS AB TEN
TWENTY EIGHT WITH SUPPORT LOCAL
SCHOOL AND COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT EFFORTS TO INSTALL COST
EFFECTIVE ENERGY PROJECTS BY
EXPANDING LIST OF ELIGIBLE
EXPENDITURES.
UNDER THE CLEAN ENERGY JOB
CREATION FUND AND TWENTY TWELVE
CALIFORNIA VOTERS APPROVED PROP
THIRTY NINE A MEASURE THAT
INCREASED STATE REVENUES BY ONE
BILLION ANNUALLY AND ALLOCATED
HALF OF THE REVENUE TO CLEAN
ENERGY JOB CREATION FUND. FOR
ENERGY PROJECTS STATEWIDE.
AS OF JUNE TWENTY EIGHTEEN
APPROXIMATELY ONE POINT SEVEN
BILLION IMPROPER NINE PROJECTS
FOR APPROVED A K. THROUGH TWELVE
SCHOOLS.
ACCORDING TO THE CALIFORNIA
ENERGY COMMISSION THESE PROJECTS
ARE PROJECTED PRODUCE AN
ESTIMATED A HUNDRED AND FIVE
MILLION IN ANNUAL ENERGY COST
SAVINGS AND SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS.
THIS BILL WOULD EXPAND THE LIST
OF EXPENDITURES TO INCLUDE
EMPLOYEE TRAINING AND ENERGY
MANAGERS AND WILL HELP MAINTAIN
AND MONITOR THESE PROJECTS.
ADDITIONALLY IN PROVIDING GRANT
ALLOCATIONS ASSISI WILL
PRIORITIZE PROJECTS THAT YOU'D
LIKE STATE FRIENDSHIP AND PRE
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS.
BY EXPANDING THE CLEAN ENERGY
JOB CREATION PROGRAM CALIFORNIA
TAKES STEPS TOWARD MEETING OUR
CLIMATE GOALS WHILE REDUCING
ENERGY COST AT SCHOOLS AND
PROVIDING A PIPELINE. FOR
SKILLED WORK FORCE AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FROM ABOUT
THANK YOU WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
DAVE WALRATH REPRESENTING SCHOOL
ENERGY COALITION A WE'RE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL -- THE
AUTHOR LAID OUT THE ISSUES AND
THE ADVANTAGES AND HOW IT HELPS
SCHOOLS AS WELL AS CREATE GOOD
PAYING JOBS.
IN INCREASES OUR PIPELINE IS
SKILLED WORKERS ALL OF WHICH WE
NEED THE SAVINGS AT SCHOOLS GO
BACK INTO THE CLASSROOM.
SO IT'S AN ASSISTANCE TO HELP
MEET OUR EDUCATIONAL GOALS AS
WELL AS CLIMB MICHAEL'S WINS FOR
THE BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN FOR
THE COMMITTEE JEREMY SMITH YOUR
BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL WERE
ALWAYS SUPPORTIVE OF BILLS THAT --
EXPAND THE USE OF PROCESS WHICH
IT PRETTY PRESSURE PROGRAMS
WHICH ARE SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THE TEACHER MEMBERS MIKE MONACAN
WE HAVE THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF LEXICAL WORKERS
THE CALIFORNIA STATE BY PRINCE
COUNCIL IN THE WESTERN STATES
COUNCIL OF THE WORKERS.
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU SO MUCH MONEY AND AND OTHERS
IN SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANYONE HERE IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEN KNOWN PRETTY BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE AND AND IT'S A GREAT
BILL -- IT'S JUST -- EXCELLENT
IS WHICH WE HAVE THE MONEY TO
USE BUT THIS AN EXCEL HIS WIFE'S --
FOR FOR THAT WHEN IT OCCURS.
THANK YOU FOR THAT WE WILL
ESTABLISH A ROOM -- YEP SORRY
SENATOR JACKSON'S GOOD MORNING
GOOD MORNING.
I'M GLAD I'M HERE BECAUSE I
THINK THIS IS A GREAT BIG.
THE BILL AS WELL.
I JUST HAVE ONE CONCERN THAT I
HAVE.
AND I KNOW THE AUTHOR HAS
EXPRESSED OVER THE COURSE OF
MANY YEARS.
AND THAT IS.
GETTING MORE WOMEN.
I INTO THE PROGRAM SO AND I
KEEPING ASSURE THAT THEY'RE
TRYING.
AND AFTER ONE HERE NOW BUT
TWENTY YEARS ON AND OFF -- I'M
WONDERING HOW WE'RE DOING AND
I'M WONDERING IF THERE MIGHT BE
SOME OPPORTUNITY.
TO BILLS.
THAT WE NEED TO HAVE SOME
PERCENTAGE OF WOMEN WHO ARE IN
THESE PROGRAMS BECAUSE I I I
KNOW THAT -- IT'S TRYING BUT I'M
NOT SURE THERE'S A LOT F
SUCCESS AND I THINK WE NEED.
TO ESTABLISH SOME KIND OF
CRITERIA THAT DEMONSTRATES THAT
THIS COMMITMENT.
NOT ONLY IS REAL.
BUT EFFECTIVE SO -- IF YOU COULD
IT IS A QUESTION THAT SYNERGIZE
THAT'S A GREAT POINT AND I WAS
IN LIGHTENED UP A COUPLE WEEKS
AGO AND APPRENTICESHIP MOVIE
THAT I WITNESSED AND SAW THAT.
THE GREAT SUCCESS ALONG THOSE
SAME THOSE LINES -- IN TRYING TO
ENGAGE MORE A WOMEN INTO THE
PROFESSIONS AND THIS TO THE IS
IN NEED OF HAPPY THOUGH TO
ANSWER I AGREE BEFORE I CAME
HERE WHEN THINGS I DID RUN WAS
OF PRE APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM --
WITH THE BUILDING TRADES TO GET
NGUYEN IN ALL FOLKS INTO --
TRADE APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS
AND I WILL SAY I AM WITH.
GOING OUT AND RECRUITING WOMEN --
GETTING THEM TRAINED UP
GUARANTEEING THEM PUT BASICALLY
GUARANTEE THEM POSITIONS IN
APPRENTICESHIPS GUARANTEEING
THEM LIKE JOBS IMMEDIATELY
BECAUSE OF OF SOME -- FEDERAL
GOALS WE WERE TRYING TO MAKE --
WE WOULD HAVE WOMEN GO THROUGH
ARGUES BUILD A PRE
APPRENTICESHIP WHO AT THE END
WOULD SAY I JUST DON'T WANT TO
DO THIS AND SO.
I I THINK I'M PROBABLY A LITTLE
SOFTER ON THE TRADE ON THIS
BECAUSE I WAS INVOLVED IN THAT
RECRUITMENT RETENTION --
PROGRAMMING THAT WE TRY TO DEAL.
IT'S NOT AN EXCUSE -- BUT WE
ALSO HAVE TO HAVE WOMEN WHO WANT
TO DO THIS WORK AND I'M AND
ALTHOUGH THERE HAS BEEN SUCCESS
IT'S WILL FULL -- IF YOU
COMPARED OF COURSE TO NON UNION
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS IT'S
OVERWHELMINGLY LIKE OVER 90% OF
THE WOMEN WHO ARE WHO GO ON TO
JOURNEY LEVEL POSITIONS ARE.
GO THROUGH A JOINT LABOR
MANAGEMENT APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAM -- SO SO THE THE TRADES
ARE DOING FAR BETTER THAN --
THEIR THEIR NON UNION
COUNTERPARTS -- BUT WE WE HAVE A
IT'S IT'S LARGER DISCUSSION AND
I THINK WE SHOULD PUT SOME GOALS
AND EVERYTHING BUT IT'S
SOMETHING I THINK WE MAYBE EVEN
US AS AS WOMEN LEGISLATORS HAVE
TO FIGURE OUT.
HOW DO WE GET WOMEN -- GIRLS
MORE EXCITED ABOUT THESE
OPPORTUNITIES BECAUSE WE'VE
WE'VE SEEN TIME AND TIME AGAIN --
AND KIND OF GO THROUGH THE STEPS
OF OF OF EVEN THE PRE
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM BE LIKE
HEY THAT'S NOT WHAT I WANT TO DO --
WHICH WE HAVE TO RESPECT I MEAN
WE CAN'T FORCE PEOPLE TO TAKE A
JOB THAT THEY DON'T WANT.
I'M MAEVE MAYBE WE'RE NOT
STARTING EARLY ENOUGH I I THINK
AND AND THIRTY THERE'S ALWAYS OF
COURSE THE OUTSTANDING ISSUE OF
BATHROOMS ON THE JOB SITE WHICH
I THINK IS SOMETHING THAT WE CAN
AND SHOULD ADDRESS.
IT IS SIMPLY CHAIR OF MEMBER
SIDE THANK YOU CENTER JACKSON
AND AND DOES A VERY.
A GOOD EXPLANATION BY -- THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER REGARDING THE
RECRUITMENT EFFORTS -- BUT WE
ALSO ALIGNED THE POLICY THROUGH
THE PRE APPRENTICESHIP
REQUIREMENTS THAT ARE IN STATE
LAW SO RIGHT NOW OF ANY --
WORKFORCE INVESTMENT BOARD
DOLLARS FUND ANY PRE
APPRENTICESHIP WORK AND THEY
HAVE TO HAVE A PLAN FOR THE ACT
OF RECRUITMENT AND RETENTION OF
WOMEN IN PRE APPRENTICESHIP.
AND THAT IS TO CREATE THE
EXPOSURE THOSE PRE
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS ARE ALSO
REQUIRED TO PARTNER WITH THE
LOCAL BUILDING TRADES COUNCILS.
THEN OUR PROJECT LABOR
AGREEMENTS ARE ALSO
INCENTIVIZING THE LOCAL HIGHER
PROVISIONS ARE ALSO TARGETING
HIRING WOMEN ON THE JOB SITE.
IN ADDITION TO THAT -- WHEN YOU
PASSED SB ONE THERE WAS A
REQUIREMENT FOR EVERY PUBLIC
AGENCY TO ACTUALLY GO OUT INTO
THE COMMUNITIES AND ALSO TARGET
FOR PRE APPRENTICESHIP
PREPARATION -- WOMEN -- PEOPLE
THAT LIVE IN THE COMMUNITY
MINORITIES L. G. B. T. NOT ONLY
FROM THE WORK FORCE COMPONENT
BUT ALSO FROM THE EMPLOYER TYPE
SO CONTRACTORS ARE ALSO FITTING
THAT -- THERE'S ALSO OUR WORK
SURROUNDING CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION.
ABA BROTHER WAS A SENATE HEARING
TODAY ON THE ASSEMBLY OF BILL
FORTY EIGHT THAT DEALS WITH THE
BOND THERE'S ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS THERE ARE A LOT
OF TWO CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION.
WE WOULD URGE YOU TO HAVE
ASSISTANCE FOR THOSE PROGRAMS SO
THAT THEY CAN SUSTAIN AND ALSO
GET PEOPLE EARLY EXPOSED TO
THESE GREAT CAREERS IN
CONSTRUCTION.
SO THERE ARE DEFINITELY POLICY --
THAT ARE SORT OF MEETING THROUGH
THE PIPELINE FROM CAREER TACK TO
PRE APPRENTICESHIP AND THEN THE
PARTNERSHIPS FOR THE HIRING.
I ALSO WANT TO NOTE THAT WE ARE
NOW OVER TWO THOUSAND WOMEN IN
THE APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS AND
WE'VE NEVER HAD THAT HIGH OF
NUMBER.
BUT IT'S BECAUSE OF THESE
RECRUITMENT EFFORTS SO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR QUESTION.
I APPRECIATE THAT -- YOU KNOW
THEY'RE SOMETIMES ARE LITTLE
THINGS LIKE LACK OF BATHROOMS.
WE KNOW THAT THAT'S IMPORTANT TO
WOMEN THEY CAN'T JUST GO OUT AND
TO THE IMPORTANCE OF MEN TO IT
AS WELL THAT'S TRUE BUT OUR
ADVISORS REQUIREMENT FOR
BATHROOMS JUST MAYBE NOT.
THE BATHROOM WE WANNA YES.
ART WELL AGAIN -- AND I WON'T
PURSUE THAT ANY FURTHER BUT I I
THINK THAT IS IT.
AND THESE ARE ALL GREAT -- BUT
THE PROOF OF THE PUDDING.
IS ALWAYS HOW MANY WOMEN THESE
ARE GREAT PAYING JOBS -- THE
WORK IS I KNOW CAN BE DIFFICULT
AND CAN BE CHALLENGING -- BUT
THEY ARE THEY THEY DO GIVE
PEOPLE THE ABILITY TO HAVE SOME
THAT FLEXIBILITY GOOD TO UNION
JOBS I'M ALL FOR THEM.
I I JUST -- I I KNOW THAT THERE
ARE SITUATIONS WHERE SOMETIMES
YOU JUST HAVE TO MAKE
ACCOMMODATIONS.
I KNOW JUDGE JUST TALKING TO A
WHOLE GROUP OF WOMEN IN THE TECH
WORLD AND A LOT OF THEM START
THEIR OWN COMPANIES BECAUSE THEY
CAN'T.
THERE'S A BROKE CULTURE.
AND I KNOW THAT THERE HAS BEEN A
BROKE KOCHHAR IN IN THE TRADES
IN IN -- YOU KNOW OF THE WORLD
AND THANK YOU IN IN THE WORLD I
WAS.
AND WE NEED TO YES.
THANK YOU I WAS TRYING TO BE
DIPLOMATIC BUT NO POINT TO THAT
SO I REALLY REALLY NEED TO WE
NEED TO INSIST I THINK THAT'S
WHAT I'M TRYING TO SAY IS YOU
KNOW IF WE HAVE O CHANGE THE
CULTURE WE HAVE TO CHANGE A
CULTURE.
WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE GETTING
WOMEN INTO THESE JOBS IN SPITE
OF ALL THOSE EFFORTS WE'VE
TALKED I KNOW BEFORE ABOUT
GETTING.
YOUNG WOMEN IT WHEN THEY'RE WHEN
THEY'RE YOUNG GIRLS I'VE TALKED
TO A BUNCH OF PEOPLE OF WOMEN
WHO WERE IN THE TRADE TO THEIR
THEIR BECAUSE I HAD AN UNCLE IN
THE TRADE OR DAD IN THE NOTION
THAT THEY COULD ACTUALLY EVEN.
CONSIDER THAT AS AN OPTION -- IS
SOMETHING THAT WE HAVE TO START
EARLIER BUT GETTING THEM INTO
THE TRAITS AND KEEPING THEM I
THINK THERE'S A TRUST IS
IMPORTANT AND I THINK WE HAVE TO
FIGURE OUT A WAY. TO CREATE
THOSE INCENTIVES GRANTED IF THEY
DON'T WANT TO STAY IN THE JOB NO
ONE SHOULD FORCE ANYBODY WHY IS
IT THAT SO.
MANY WOMEN LEAVE AND THAT'S
REALLY WHERE I TO SEE SOME
EFFORT THROUGH SOMEKIND OF
pEITHER CRITERIA OR PERCENT
SOMETHING.
THAT WE HAVEN'T SO WHERE WE SEE
A LOT MORE WOMEN IN THE FIELD
THROUGH THROUGH THE CHAIR JUST
ANSWER THAT WE TOTALLY AGREE
WITH EVERYTHING THAT YOU
MENTIONED AND WE ARE WORKING NOT
ONLY -- TO IN TERS OF THE
RECRUITMENT BUT ALSO THE
RETENTION RIGHT BECAUSE WE CAN
HAVE A GREAT WERE RECRUITED BUT
IF THE JOB SITE CULTURE.
ISN'T ALLOWING PEOPLE TO
ACTUALLY STAY IN FEEL
COMFORTABLE AND FEEL SAFE THEN
WE HAVE PROBLEMS AND WE LOSE
THAT OPPORTUNITY AND WE LOSE
ALSO THAT INVESTMENT.
IN THAT APPRENTICE BECAUSE IT
DOES.
COST A LOT OF DOLLARS TO
ACTUALLY IS BEST IN THE TRAINING
FOR THAT PERSON.
SO FOR THAT REASON LAST YEAR WE
RAN A BILL BY A SIMILAR MCCARTY
YOUR THAT DEALT WITH THE
PARTNERSHIP PROTECTIONS FROM
HARASSMENT.
HOW THE CURRICULUM HAVE TRAINING
FOR EVERY SINGLE APPRENTICE
THAT'S GOING THROUGH THAT
PROGRAM ARE ALSO EXTENDED
PROTECTIONS FOR OF THE
APPRENTICE ON THE JOB SITE SO
FOR EXAMPLE IF A CONTRACTOR?
IS NOT FULFILLING THEIR
OBLIGATIONS FOR PROTECTING THAT
APPRENTICE FROM HARASSMENT
DISCRIMINATION OUR PARTNERSHIP
PROGRAMS CAN PULL THE APPRENTICE
BACK BECAUSE IT'S A PRIVILEGE TO
HAVE AN APPRENTICE ON THE JOB
SITE.
BIG BIG GET PAID 40% OF THE
PREVAILING WAGE RATE OF COURSE
IT'S LESS FOR WHAT THE
CONTRACTOR PAYS OUT.
SO THAT'S ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WE'RE DOING AND THEN THIS YEAR
RUNNING ANOTHER PIECE OF
LEGISLATION THAT COULD BE TOLD
LAST YEAR BY -- GOVERNOR BROWN
SB FIVE THIRTY BY CENTER
GALGIANI THAT WOULD CREATE AN
ADVISORY COMMITTEE TO PROVIDE
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR CONSTRUCTION
INDUSTRY SPECIFIC SEXUAL
HARASSMENT DISCRIMINATION
POLICIES.
AND WE'RE INCLUDING COMPLIANCE
WITH -- MITCH -- SENATOR
MITCHELL'S BILL FROM LAST YEAR --
SB FIFTEEN THIRTY WANTS TO MAKE
SURE THAT IN THE CONSTRUCTION
INDUSTRY THEY KEEP THE
CERTIFICATE FOR TWO YEARS AND
THERE'S A DATABASE ALSO
RECORDING THAT THEY'VE COMPLY
WITH THESE REQUIREMENTS BECAUSE
IT THERE ARE MULTI EMPLOYER --
ENVIRONMENT AND THEIR DIFFERENT
DIFFERENT EMPLOYERS FOR YOU KNOW.
SIX MONTHS WITHIN SIX MONTHS
COULD BE WORKING FOR SIX
DIFFERENT CONTRACTORS SO MY LAST
QUESTION IF I MAY MISTER CHAIR
TO THE BILL.
I KNOW THAT THIS IS AS IMPORTANT
TO YOU -- IS THERE ANYTHING THAT
YOU -- HAVE CONSIDERED OR WOULD
CONSIDER TO ASSURE THAT -- THERE.
THAT THAT WE SEE MORE WOMEN --
STAYING IN THESE FIELDS BECAUSE
THIS IS SEEMS TO ME TO BE A GOOD
VEHICLE. TO TO HAVE THAT HAPPEN
WELL EVERYTHING REFERENCED -- BY --
MISTER DE AS IS IN THE BILL
BECAUSE OF THE APPRENTICESHIP
LANGUAGE ARE YOU SAID MC THREE
STUFF IS IN THE BILL VIA THE
APPRENTICESHIP LANGUAGE.
I'M.
I WOULD REALLY SUGGEST JUST
GIVEN MY EXPERIENCE AND I
THERE'S A LOT I I THINK THAT THE
TRADES.
ARE ARE CAPTURING AT THE JOB
LEVEL THE PERNICIOUS LEVEL
THAT'S IMPORTANT AGAIN I THINK
IN SOME WAYS IT'S GOING TO TAKE
US TO NUMBER ONE IT'S NOT JUST A
WOMEN A GIRLS ISSUE THERE ARE A
LOT OF WE HAVE A GRAIN OF WORK
FORCE IF YOU WILL IN
CONSTRUCTION.
AND A LOT OF THAT IN IN A LOT OF
THAT IS THIS IDEA THAT --
SOMEHOW GOING TO COLLEGE IS THE
PATH FOR EVERY FIRST GRADER.
COMING AND GOING FIRST GRADER
YOU KNOW AND NOT REALLY
INTRODUCING A NUMBER OF OUR KIDS
TO ADD ALTERNATIVE PATH THAT IS
A GOOD JOB AND AND VALUING
CONSTRUCTION WORK AS WORK WE WE
DON'T TEND TO VALUE -- A LOT OF
WORK AND AND WE MAKE THAT VERY
CLEAR I THINK TO OUR SCHOOL AGE
CHILDREN -- IT'S IT'S WEIRD WITH
CONSTRUCTION WORK RIGHT BECAUSE
IT IS REALLY CAN BE A VERY GOOD
CAREER -- AND YET SOMEHOW YOU
KNOW WE WE DON'T EXPRESS THAT WE
CERTAINLY DON'T EXPRESS THAT TO
LITTLE GIRLS.
AND SO I I THINK WHERE.
WE CAN BE HELPFUL IN MAYBE NOT
THIS BILL BUT WE SHOULD THINK
ABOUT THIS BE HAPPY TO WORK WITH
YOU IS.
IS HOW DO WE GET YOUNG GIRLS IN
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL TO START SEEN
THEM AT THIS IS A POSSIBILITY OF
A FUTURE FOR THEM YOU KNOW -- IF
YOU LOOK AT YOU YOU CAN GIVE A
HAMMER NOT A REAL ONE OF COURSE
TO I CAN GARNER MALE OR FEMALE
THEY'RE BOTH GOING TO EQUALLY
PLAY WITH IT BUT BY THE TIME YOU
GET -- TO THESE WOMEN WHO ARE
YOU KNOW.
SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN MAYBE
THEY'RE NOT SEEN THEMSELVES IN
THAT JOB SO I THINK WE HAVE WE
HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY -- AND IN
THE TRADES I KNOW WHAT PARTNER
IN THAT BUT THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT I WOULD LIKE TO SEE A STEEL
AND IT GOES LIKE I SAID ON THOSE
TWO FRONTS ONE HELPING YOUNG
WOMEN SEE THEMSELVES IN THAT.
JOB AND TO VALUING WORK I MEAN
VALUE IN WORKING WITH YOUR HANDS
AND DOING REAL WORK THAT DOESN'T
INCLUDE NECESSARILY A COLLEGE
DEGREE AND I THINK WE THOSE ARE
SOME OF THINGS THAT WE ARE
LACKING IN OUR HOW WE APPROACH.
SO OUR STUDENTS AND AND I AGREE
WITH EVERY BIT OF THAT I'M JUST
WONDERING IF THERE'S SOME KIND
OF YOU KNOW WHEN YOU SAID A A
REQUIREMENT THAT HAS TO BE MET --
PEOPLE ARE.
WILL FIGURE OUT HOW TO MEET IT.
AND AND I JUST WONDER IF THERE'S
SOMETHING THAT WE COULD DO THAT
WOULD.
YOU KNOW KNOW WE HAVE FANS BUT
RIGHT EXCUSES FIGURE IT OUT GET
THERE I I'M JUST AFRAID WE
WOULDN'T THERE'S JUST NO
POSSIBLE WAY TO MEET THAT RIGHT
IN ANY ANYTHING THAT IS UP
SUBSTANCE REALLY -- YOU KNOW I
AM WERE NOT THERE IT WORK WERE
SO FAR AT THE I CAN'T EXPLAIN TO
YOU THE FRUSTRATION I HAD WHEN.
WE WOULD WE WOULD PUT -- THESE
YOUNG WOMEN OFTEN SINGLE MOMS
YOU KNOW THEY WERE THEY WERE
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN YEARS OLD ARE
YOU STILL PROGRAM WE GET THEM
THEIR GED SOMETIMES ARE HIGH
SCHOOL DIPLOMA.
PREPARE THEM FOR AN
APPRENTICESHIP EXAM AND EXPOSE
THEM TO A CONTROLLED WORK SITE
SAID THEY DIDN'T HAVE SOME THE
SAME ISSUES WITH REAL BATHROOMS
AND AND FEMALES ON THE JOB.
AND YET STILL. TO THE TEA EVERY
SINGLE STUDENT WHO CAME THROUGH
A PRE APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM WHO
IS A FEMALE CHOSE NOT TO GO INTO
THE APPRENTICESHIP TRAITS AND SO
IT WASN'T -- AND I THOUGHT NOT
IN A CONTROLLED ENVIRONMENT IF
WE CAN'T CONVINCE SEES THESE
YOUNG WOMEN WITH THE OPPORTUNITY
OF A GOOD JOB AND THEY TAKE.
YEAH I THINK I'M AGO -- WORK FOR
YOU PASS ARE GONNA GO YOU WHICH
IS GREAT IT'S GOOD JOB TOO BUT
YOU KNOW I WE WE WOULD PROVIDE
THEM WITH OTHER OPPORTUNITIES
CAME THROUGH THE LABOR COUNCIL
SO WE'RE TRYING TO PROVIDE THEM
A GOOD UNION JOB.
BUT I COULD NOT GET A SINGLE
YOUNG WOMAN THROUGH THAT PROGRAM
TO GO INTO THE TRADE SO WE'VE
WE'VE GOT.
REAL PIPELINE PROBLEM THANK
YOUNG THANK YOU SENATOR MITCHELL.
I WAS JUST GOING TO ADD TO TO IT --
THAT THAT I AGREE AT AT ARMS TO
DISS INVITATION HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS THE
INTERNATIONAL -- WOMEN IN THE
BUILDING TRADES CONFERENCE A
COUPLE OF YEARS AGO WHEN I
WALKED IN THE CONVENTION CENTER
I WAS BLOWN AWAY THAT THER ARE
HUNDREDS OF WOMEN FROM ALL OVER
THE WORLD.
COUPLE THAT EXPERIENCE AND AND
TO HEAR FROM THEM WOMEN WHO
SPENT THEIR ENTIRE CAREERS AND
TALKED ABOUT THE CHALLENGES.
COUPLE THAT WITH THE WOMEN AT
FOLSOM PRISON HERE WHO ARE
GRADUATING WITH MULTIPLE
CERTIFICATES IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
THE BUILDING TRADES AND I THINK
IT'S THE OTHER WORK WE DO IT'S
EASY TO PUT OUT A QUOTA.
BUT IF THE OTHER WORK WE DO IN
EDUCATION IT'S THE WORK WE'RE
DOING AROUND -- WORKPLACE
HARASSMENT.
THAT WILL CREATE THE ENVIRONMENT
IN WHICH IT WILL BE SAFE AND
COMFORTABLE AND ATTRACTIVE TO
WOMEN TO GO.
THE WOMEN I MET THE WORK SITE
OUT AT THE NEW A KAISER FACILITY
OF MY DISTRICT OF THE
ELECTRICIANS THE WOMEN I WORKED
WITH.
THE MET AND TALKED TO TALKED
ABOUT THE DIFFERENCE IT MAKES
WHEN THERE'S A WOMAN ON THE SIDE
IN THE SUPER BIZARRO POSITION.
WHO THEY CAN SEE THEMSELVES TO
HER AND THEY ALSO KNW HER BEING
THERE AND IN A LEADERSHIP ROLE
CREATES A CULTURE ON THE WORK
SITE THAT'S EVEN UNSPOKEN?
NO DIFFERENT THAN OUR EFFORT TO
GET MORE WOMEN ELECTED JUST AT
YOUR WORK AROUND OUT WOMEN
APPOINTED TO BOARDS AND AND ALL
THE RESEARCH SHOWS NOT JUST ONE
WOMAN CAN MAKE A DIFFERENCE BUT
IF THERE'S THREE ON THE BOARDS
IT MAKES A DIFFERENCE IN TERMS
OF THE EXPERIENCE OF A WOMAN.
BEING THERE SO WE HAVE TO WE
HAVE TO IT'S IT'S AN ORGANIC
ISSUE THAT WE HAVE TO DEAL WITH
IT IN OUR EDUCATION SYSTEM.
OUR WORKPLACE SAFETY IN CULTURE
SYSTEM ALL OF THOSE AREAS.
I THINK WE'LL CREATE YOU KNOW
THE OPPORTUNITY -- FOR WOMEN TO
TO SEE IT IN A VERY DIFFERENT
LIFE WAS NOT JEST.
PUSHING BACK ON YOU ALL IN TERMS
OF THE PRINT TO SHIP TO ALL THE
OTHER WORK WE HAVE TO DO
COLLECTIVELY TO KIND OF CREATE
THE DESIRE.
AND THE CULTURE AND THE SAFETY
AND THE BEING ABLE TO SEE
YOURSELF IN THAT PROFESSION SO I
SUPPORT THE BILL -- HAVE YOU
ALREADY VISITED AB FIFTY ONE NOT
YET OKAY GREAT WE NEXT IN AND WE
WILL I DO NOT KNOW ESTABLISH A
QUORUM.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
I'LL MOVE THE BILL WHEN IT'S
APPROPRIATE.
SENATOR HILL HERE CENTER HILL
HERE MORRELL.
HERE MORRELL HERE JACKSON.
ROUTE JACKSON HERE MITCHELL HERE
MITCHELL HERE PATH.
WE DO HAVE A QUORUM ESTABLISHED
AND WE HAVE A MOTION FROM US
SENATOR MITCHELL WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE.
AS AT LOOK FOR TO TO WORKING
WITH -- YOU SENATORS ON A
HOLISTIC APPROACH TO THIS I
THINK THAT WILL CONTINUE -- WE
WEEK IF WE FIND SOMETHING WE CAN
PUT IN THE BILL AYE AYE I THINK
WERE A COUPLE YEARS OFF BEFORE
WE CAN FIND A FUNDING SOURCE FOR
THIS BILL SO.
WE HAVE SOME TIME TO CONTINUE TO
WORK ON THIS I BELIEVE.
HOPEFULLY AS IT PASSES THANK YOU
THANK YOU THE MOTION TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO ENERGY UTILITIES AND
COMMUNICATIONS COMMITTEE PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
NUMBER [inaudible]
TWO AND I WOULD APPROPRIATIONS.
I THOUGHT IT.
CREATION.
WOULD DETERMINE WHERE IT GOES
FROM HERE IS THE PERCENTAGE
COMMITTEE.
QUESTIONS [inaudible]
SENATOR HILL.
HI.
I'M AROUND.
MORRELL NO JACKSON.
CHECK ON MITCHELL AYE MITCHELL
AYE PAN.
IT HAS THREE VOTES ON OF TO GET
UP WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR
THE ACTION MEMBER THANK YOU AND
WE'LL MOVE NOT ITEM NUMBER ONE
AB FIFTY ONE PLEASE.
PROCEED.
THANK YOU.
I'M AB FIFTY ONE I THINK YOU
HAVE ALL SEEN BEFORE I BRING IT
BACK TO BACK THIS YEAR AFTER IT
WAS VETOED BY GOVERNOR BROWN.
IT IS SIMPLY A PROHIBITION
AGAINST -- BINDING ARBITRATION
FORCE BINDING ARBITRATION
AGREEMENTS AS A CONDITION OF
EMPLOYMENT IT'S NARROWLY CRAFTED
TO HOPEFULLY AVOID ON THE THE
CHALLENGE OF A COURT DECISION --
OF COURSE IT WILL GET TAKEN TO
COURT IF IT PASSES AND GET
SIGNED -- BUT WE THINK THIS IS
AN APPROACH THAT ENSURES THAT
ARBITRATION AGREEMENTS ARE
ENTERED INTO VOLUNTARILY WE
DON'T BELIEVE THERE'S ANYTHING
WRONG WITH ARBITRATION
AGREEMENTS WHEN TWO PARTIES
ENTER INTO IT VOLUNTARILY.
IT'S NOT MEANT TO DISCOURAGE THE
USE OF A VOLUNTARY ARBITRATION
AGREEMENTS IT'S SIMPLY -- MEANT
TO ENSURE THAT AS WE CONTINUE TO
CREATE REALLY STRONG ROBUST
LABOR LAWS IN CALIFORNIA THAT
THEY'RE ACTUALLY IT HERE TOO AND
THAT THAT A WORKER HAS THE
OPPORTUNITY. TO UTILIZE EITHER
THE COURT SYSTEM OR THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER TO ENSURE THAT
THEIR RIGHTS -- IN THE WORKPLACE
ARE ARE RESPECTED -- AND THAT
THEY DON'T HAVE TO GIVE THAT UP
AS A CONDITION TO GETTING A JOB
OR GETTING -- A RAISE OR OR
GETTING PROMOTED SO WITHOUT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK HIM ABOUT HAVE
A COUPLE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FIRST WITH THIS IN SUPPORT MR
CHEN MEMBERS CAITLIN VEGA FOR
THE CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
WE ARE SPONSORS OF THIS BILL.
I'M ONCE AGAIN.
AT YOUR ANALYSIS POINTS OUT THAT
IN.
TWENTY TWELVE ONLY 16% OF
WORKERS WERE IN THESE ARE.
MANDATORY ARBITRATION AGREEMENTS
WHAT HAPPENED AFTER THAT WAS A
SUPREME COURT DECISION --
ESTABLISHING THAT EMPLOYERS
COULD REQUIRE WORKERS TO SIGN
AWAY THEIR RIGHTS AS A CONDITION
OF EMPLOYMENT AND SINCE THAT
TIME WE HAVE SEEN THE NUMBERS
SKYROCKET AND WE'VE REALLY SEEN
THE USE OF THESE AGREEMENTS
CHANGE.
INITIALLY THEY WERE SOMETHING
THAT WAS MORE COMMON IN A
CORPORATE SETTING. FOR
EXECUTIVES WHO WERE MAYBE MORE
IN A POSITION TO NEGOTIATE OVER
THE TERMS OF THEIR WORK WHAT WE
SEE NOW IS THAT VIRTUALLY EVERY
FAST FOOD WORKER.
IS SENDING A FORCED ARBITRATION
AGREEMENT IN ORDER TO GET THEIR
JOB THESE ARBITRATION AGREEMENTS
ARE USED PREDOMINANTLY IN THE
INDUSTRIES THAT ARE.
ALMOST ENTIRELY WOMEN IN THE
INDUSTRIES THAT ARE PEOPLE OF
COLOR AND MOST IN INDUSTRIES
THAT ARE WOMEN OF COLOR THAT.
CAME OUT IN A REPORT BY THE
ECONOMIC POLICY INSTITUTE SO IN
THE CONTEXT OF OUR LAST
CONVERSATION BECAUSE I ALWAYS.
LOVE IN LABOR COMMITTEE HOW ALL
ISSUES TIED TOGETHER ACROSS
BILLS IN THE CONTEXT OF THAT
LAST CONVERSATION ABOUT THE
CHALLENGES WOMEN FACE ON THE JOB
IN WHETHER IT'S IN MALE
DOMINATED INDUSTRIES.
WHETHER IT'S ISSUES AROUND --
WAGE THEFT WHICH IS OFTEN LINKED
TO SEXUAL HARASSMENT THOSE AT
THOSE TEND TO HAPPEN TOGETHER --
ALL OF THOSE KINDS OF ABUSES
THAT BOTH WOMEN AND MEN SUFFER
ON THE JOB AND THAT LOW WAGE
WORKERS SUFFER MOST.
THOSE WORKERS ARE TRAPPED IN THE
EMPLOYERS PRIVATE CONFIDENTIAL
ARBITRATION SYSTEM THAT MEANS
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THOSE
WORKERS MAY BE GETTING HARASSED
BY THE SAME PERSON.
THEY DON'T HAVE THE RIGHT TO
KNOW ABOUT EACH OTHER THEY DON'T
HAVE THE RIGHT TO GO TO COURT
TOGETHER.
NO ONE OUTSIDE THAT COMPANY
KNOWS THAT THE SAME PERSON IS
ENGAGING IN REPEATED SEXUAL
HARASSMENT LAST YEAR WE BROUGHT
OUT GRETCHEN CARLSON WHO HAD
BEEN THE FOX NEWS ANCHOR.
ON WHO'S ONE OF THE MOST FAMOUS
EXAMPLES OF THIS HAPPENING WHERE.
WE KNOW BECAUSE OF THESE FORCED
ARBITRATION AGREEMENTS THERE WAS
WIDESPREAD HARASSMENT FOR YEARS
AND YEARS AND YEARS THAT WAS
NEVER DEALT WITH BECAUSE IT
PROTECTED THE ABUSERS.
SADLY STATES ARE VERY LIMITED IN
WHAT THEY CAN DO IN THIS ARENA
THE SCOPE OF FEDERAL PREEMPTION
IS VERY BROAD.
THAT'S WHY ALL THIS BILL DOES IS
MAKE IT OPTIONAL IT SAYS THE
EMPLOYER CAN USE FORCE A
MANDATORY ARBITRATION THEY CAN
USE ARBITRATION.
OF ALL DISPUTES THEY CAN CLOSE
OFF YOUR ABILITY TO GO TO COURT
TO GO TO THE LABOR COMMISSIONER
TO GET ANY ASSISTANCE OUTSIDE OF
THE EMPLOYERS HIRED ARBITRATOR.
BUT THEY HAVE TO GIVE YOU THAT
CHOICE STAFF TO TALK YOU INTO IT.
AND THE OPPONENTS OFTEN TALK
ABOUT HOW THEY THINK ARBITRATION
IS A BETTER SYSTEM FOR WORKERS
FOR LOW WAGE WORKERS THAT'S IN
SPITE OF ALL THE RESEARCH
SHOWING THAT WORKERS LOSE AN
ARBITRATION.
THE WORDS ARE MUCH SMALLER AN
ARBITRATION BUT THEY SAY THEY
ARE VERY GOOD FOR WORKERS ARE
ARGUMENTIS.
THEN PERSUADE WORKERS TO SIGN
THESE AGREEMENTS DON'T MAKE THE
MANDATORY THAT'S ALL THIS BILL
DOES THANK YOU BUT THERE'S IN
SUPPORT.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THE
COMMISSION INVESTMENT ON BEHALF
OF THE TEAMSTERS SAG AFTRA ABOUT
A MINUTE TRANSIT UNION
MACHINISTS I OF P. T. LOCAL.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND THE
CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF CALIFORNIA
ALL IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
HIS BIGGEST SAID IT.
QUITE WELL THE ARBITRATION
FORCED ARBITRATION WHEN PEOPLE
DON'T HAVE CHOICE IS.
DIFFERENT THAN A PROCESS WHERE
PEOPLE ARE BOTH GOING INTO IT
ALL ENTIRELY.
AND IN OUR VIEW.
THIS PROCESS HAS TURNED INTO.
A VENUE ARBITRATION THAT ISN'T
ABOUT PROCEDURE IT'S ABOUT
SUPPRESSING PEOPLE'S RIGHTS THAT
YOU WALL GIVEN THEM AND YOUR
PREDECESSORS HAVE GIVEN THEM.
IMPORTANT LABOR RIGHTS
PROTECTIONS IN THE WORK.
AN ARBITRATION OUR VIEW BECAUSE
OF THE STATISTICS ABOUT HOW
OFTEN THE WORKERS WHEN AND ALSO
BECAUSE WORKERS JUST ARE
DISCOURAGED TO GO THROUGH THIS
PROCESS ALONE.
BY THEMSELVES WITHOUT AN
ATTORNEY.
AND IT'S DONE.
IT'S THE EMPLOYERS ENTIRE
PROCESS IT'S GREAT FOR THEM AND
IT DISCOURAGES FOLKS FROM
BRINGING CLAIMS SO.
IN OUR VIEW THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT BILL SO THAT PEOPLE
CAN HAVE THEIR SUBSTANTIVE
RIGHTS PROTECTED AND WE ARE
DRIVE UP THANK YOU [inaudible]
PORT.
MR CHAIRMAN.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE CHRISTY
VELMA WE HAVE A THREE GROUPS
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS.
A CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS AND THE WRITERS GUILD
OF AMERICA WEST ALL IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK YOU
AS WELL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN OF THE
COMMITTEE JEREMY SMITH YOUR
BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL ALSO
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING JESSICA CENTER ON
BEHALF OF EQUAL RIGHTS ADVOCATES
AND THE STRONGER CALIFORNIA
ADVOCATES NETWORK IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
TEACHER MEMBERS MIKE BONTA GONNA
BE HAVE THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS THE CALIFORNIA STATE I
PREACH COUNCIL IN THE WESTERN
STATES COUNCIL OF SHEET METAL
WORKERS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
VERY CLEAR SHE HARM HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA PLAN MILLERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
RENEE BY RSA YOU CALIFORNIA ALSO
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
THOSE IN OPPOSITION PLEASE COME
FORWARD [inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING -- ON THE HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
AND WE ARE OPPOSED AB -- FIFTY
ONE I AGREE WITH A LOT OF
COMMENTS THAT THE PROPONENTS
ACTUALLY MADE I DO BELIEVE THAT
THIS WILL BE IMMEDIATELY
CHALLENGED IF PASSED AND SIGNED
INTO LAW GOVERNOR BROWN VETOED
ALMOST THE EXACT SAME BILL LAST
YEAR -- AND SAID A PLANE AT
PLAINLY VIOLATES FEDERAL LAW AND
EVEN CITED TO SOME OF THE
SUPREME COURT CASES THAT HAVE
BEEN DECIDED OVER THE LAST TEN
YEARS THAT HAVE CONSISTENTLY
HELD.
THAT ANY STATE LAW THAT SEEKS TO
INTERFERE WITH THIS --
DISCRIMINATE AGAINST OR LIMIT
THE USE OF ARBITRATION
AGREEMENTS WILL BE PRINTED IN
THE FEDERAL ARBITRATION ACT IT'S
A FEDERAL ISSUE IT'S NOT A STATE
ISSUE UNTIL THE FEDERAL
ARBITRATION ACT CHANGES THERE'S
NOT A LOT THAT STATES CAN DO IN
THIS AREA -- A BILL THAT WAS
PASSED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER
AND SIGNED INTO LAW A FEW YEARS
AGO ALSO SAID THAT AS A
CONDITION OF A CONSUMER CONTRACT --
YOU COULD NOT HAVE AN
ARBITRATION BECAUSE IT WAS THE
SAME ARGUMENT MADE THAT IT HAS
TO BE VOLUNTARY AND THAT YOU
CAN'T DO IT AS A CONDITION OF A
CONTRACT.
THIS BILL IS THAT PROPONENTS
HAVE A PRESENTED SAYS THAT AS A
CONDITION OF EMPLOYMENT CONTRACT
YOU CANNOT HAVE AN ARBITRATION
CLAUSE.
THE BILL WAS STRUCK DOWN BY THE
SECOND DISTRICT COURT OF APPEAL
AND THE DECISION SAYING IT WAS
ALSO THAT LIMITATION ON THE
CREATION OF AN ARBITRATION
AGREEMENT WAS ALSO PREEMPTED AND
THE FEDERAL ARBITRATION ACT SO I
AGREE.
WITH PROPONENTS AGREE OF THE
AUTHOR THAT THISBILL -- IF
PASSED WILL BE CHALLENGED IN
COURT AND I WOULD SUGGEST THAT
IT WILL LIKELY BE STRUCK DOWN AS
WELL AS PRINTED IN THE FEDERAL
ARBITRATION ACT JUST LIKE THE
WEBER BILL WAS AND LIKE SEVERAL
BILLS AND OTHER A STATE LAWS
HAVE DONE UNDER THE SUPREME
COURT SO.
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE I DON'T IT
DOESN'T BENEFIT THE EMPLOYER I
CAN OBVIOUSLY SAY THAT.
THE EMPLOYER WILL BE LEFT IN
UNCERTAINTY -- AND WILL BEAR THE
COST OF LITIGATION I DON'T SEE
HOW THAT BENEFITS THE EMPLOYEES
WHEN YOU HAVE UNCERTAINTY WITH
REGARDS TO THE ENFORCEMENT OF
RIGHTS -- AND THE OTHER CONCERN
THAT I HAVE IS THAT IF YOU LIMIT --
DO USE OF ARBITRATION AGREEMENTS
WHICH THE IF THIS BILL IT GOES
FOR IT AS INTENDED WILL
CERTAINLY DO -- THE OTHER
OPTIONS FOR AN EMPLOYEE ARE THE
LABOR COMMISSIONER HEARING OR
GOING TO COURT AS AGAIN THE
PROPONENTS MENTIONED WE DON'T
HAVE A PROBLEM WITH THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER HEARING IN FACT --
I THINK THAT THAT'S AN EFFICIENT
AND EFFECTIVE WAY MUCH TO
RESOLVED LABOR DISPUTES --
WITHOUT THE COSTS ASSOCIATED
LITIGATION WHICH INCLUDES
OBVIOUSLY SIGNIFICANT COURT
COSTS AND ATTORNEYS FEES
INCLUDED IN THAT -- BUT THE
OTHER PATHWAY IS LITIGATION --
AND IF YOU'RE ABLE TO FIND THE
PLAINTIFFS ATTORNEY.
GREAT -- BUT THE DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS AND A
BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSAL THAT
SENATOR MITCHELL'S PROBABLY
FAMILIAR WITH.
CAME OUT THIS YEAR AND SAID THAT
THEY WOULDN'T THEY REVIEWED OVER
FIFTEEN HUNDRED SETTLEMENTS THAT
WERE DONE UNDER THE LABOR CODE.
IN 75% OF THOSE CASES THEY FELL
ON THAT THE PLAINTIFFS ATTORNEYS
FAILED OR GOT A MARGINALLY
PASSING RATE FOR PROTECTING
WORKERS INTERESTS.
MEANING THAT THEY WERE IN
ADEQUATE AND PROTECTING WORKERS
INTEREST ON THE DEBT LABOR CODE
AND SO AGAIN IF YOU'RE BANNING
ARBITRATION OR LIMITING THE USE
OF ARBITRATION AND YOU HAVE TO
PATHWAYS WHEN THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER'S OFFICE WHICH
CERTAINLY DOESN'T HAVE THE
FUNDING TO RESOURCES --
AVAILABLE TO HANDLE THESE CASES
AND THEN YOU'RE SENDING THEM TO
LITIGATION YOU'RE SENDING THEM
TO A FORUM IN WHICH THERE HAS
BEEN A FINDING BY OUR INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS AGENCY NOT ME.
NOT THE BUSINESS GROUPS BUT OUR
LABOR AGENCY IN WHICH THEY SAID
THAT THE PLAINTIFFS COUNSEL HAVE
FAILED IN PROTECTING WORKERS
INTERESTS SO AGAIN I DON'T SEE
HOW THIS BILL BENEFITS EMPLOYERS
I CAN SIR YOU IT DOESN'T BENEFIT
EMPLOYERS.
I DON'T SEE HOW PROTECT SIMPLY
INTERESTS AND FOR THOSE REASONS
WE ARE POST THANK YOU.
PLEASE DON'T HI CAM STONE ON
BEHALF OF THE CIVIL JUSTICE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIAN
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION.
ARBITRATION IS A LEGITIMATE FAIR
AND EFFICIENT WAY TO RESOLVE
DISPUTES -- I THINK AT SOME OF
THE UNION GROUPS AGREE WITH THAT
BECAUSE THERE IS A BILL LAST
YEAR THE YEAR BEFORE TO ALLOW
UNION GROUPS TO USE ARBITRATION
TO RESOLVE PAGA -- CLAIMS IN IN
LAWSUITS WHEN PEOPLE HAVE A
PROBLEM THEY WANT THAT PROBLEM
SOLVED AND THERE'S ACTUALLY BEEN
STUDIES WHERE PEOPLE WERE --
SURVEYED AFTER EMPLOYMENT
LITIGATION AND ARBITRATION AND
LITIGATION YIELDED ROUGHLY THE
SAME RESULTS BUT PEOPLE ON
SOMEONE IRONICALLY FELT MORE
HEARD LIKE THEY HAVE THEIR DAY
IN COURT WHEN THEY WENT THROUGH
ARBITRATION THEN IF THEY HAD
GONE THROUGH.
LITIGATION THE EIGHTEEN T.
VERSUS CONCEPCION A UNITED
STATES SUPREME COURT CONTAINED
AN ARBITRATION -- AGREEMENT THAT
WAS UNDER ATTACK THAT WAS VERY
VERY PRO CONSUME THE WAY THAT
WORKS IS IF YOU HAD A PROBLEM
YOU -- SUBMITTED YOUR PROBLEM
AND EIGHTEEN T. MADE YOU AN
OFFER TO RESOLVE IT IF YOU
DIDN'T ACCEPT THAT CLAIM AND
THE ARBITER.
AWARDED MORE THAN EIGHTEEN T.
DID YOU GOT SEVEN THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS IN DAMAGES AND
TWO TIMES YOUR ATTORNEY'S FEES.
SO ARBITRATION AGREEMENTS CAN IN
OUR CRAFTED IN LEGITIMATE AND
FAIR WAY IS THE REASONS THAT
EMPLOYERS LIKE TO USE THEM IS
THAT IT -- REDUCES THE
UNCERTAINTY AND UNPREDICTABILITY
OF SORT OF A JACKPOT JUSTICE OR
A RUNAWAY VERDICT THAT WOULD BE
VERY DIFFICULT. TO ABSORB --
CALIFORNIA LAW ARMAND ARE IS AND
OTHER CASE LAW HAS VERY EXPLICIT
LIMITATIONS ON ARBITRATION
AGREEMENTS AND CLAUSES IN
CONTRACTS THAT MUST BE FAIR IF
THEY ARE UNCONSCIONABLE OR
UNFAIR JOB -- JUDGES WILL NOT
ENFORCE THEM BECAUSE ARBITRATION
IS A LEGITIMATE FAIR AND
EFFICIENT WAY OF RESOLVING
DISPUTES WE BELIEVE IT CAN AND
SHOULD BE USED AND RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE THE SPELL.
THANK YOU MISTER JONES -- OTHERS
IN OPPOSITION PLEASE.
COME TO THE MICROPHONE.
WHERE DOES THE CALIFORNIA
ADVOCATES RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE
FOR THE FAMILY BUSINESS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA AND
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
JOINT POWERS AUTHORITY THANK YOU?
GOOD MORNING KATIE HANSON WITH
THE CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION PROPOSED AS WELL FOR
THE REASONS STATED THANK YOU.
THE CALL RICE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION WE ARE ALSO OPEN
THANK YOU HE WAS RIGHT.
GOOD MORNING KELLY MAC MILLAN ON
BEHALF OF FAMILY WHY MAKERS OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND THE WESTERN CAR WARS
ASSOCIATION WORST RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING BROWN A LITTLE
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
FEDERATION OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
MORNING DAY BUT WE'RE ON BEHALF
THE UNITED CHAMBER ADVOCACY
NETWORK A COALITION OF LOCAL
CHAMBERS OF COMMERCE AND THE
STOCK MARKET PLACE IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU MISTER BUTLER.
APOLOGIES FOR BEING OUT OF ORDER
SOUTH BRAMBLE HERE ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
WERE IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OTHERS IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
SEE NO ONE BRINGING IT BACK.
TO THE COMMITTEE AND I
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS ON BOTH
SIDES SENATOR MITCHELL.
I WAS A COOPER ON YOUR BILL LAST
TIME IN THE I DON'T THINK YOU
ASKED ME THIS YEAR MY PACKAGE
LAST YEAR IN TERMS OF LOOKING AT
KIND OF WORKPLACE CULTURE -- SO
WELL I APPRECIATE THE SHOP IN
THE OPPOSITION I'D LIKE TO BE
ASKED ADDED AS A CO OP.
THANK YOU SENATOR MITCHELSON
SENATOR -- JACKSON ME.
TOO POP BUT I ALSO HAVE SOME.
COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS -- I
THINK ARBITRATION FORCED
ARBITRATION IS ONE OF THE WORST
THINGS THAT WE'VE DONE TO
UNDERMINE JUSTICE IN THIS
COUNTRY.
THESE ARE NOT VOLUNTARY.
ARE THE WAY THE SYSTEM WORKS --
IT BASICALLY REMOVES THE ABILITY
OF PEOPLE TO HAVE MATTERS HEARD
BY A JURY OF THEIR PEERS.
I ATE IT BAFFLES ME THAT THE
UNITED STATES SUPREME COURT HAS
SAID THAT THEY ARE APPROPRIATE
AND CONSTITUTIONAL.
THAT BEING SAID AS I UNDERSTAND
THIS BILL IT'S BASICALLY
VOLUNTARY.
IT DOESN'T IT JUST SIMPLY SAYS
AN EMPLOYER CAN SAY TO YOU WE
WOULD LIKE YOU AS A CONDITION OF
EMPLOYMENT TO AGREE TO THIS
[inaudible]
ARM.
THERE ARE CLAIMS THAT THIS --
BILL REDUCES OR THAT THIS
UNDERMINES -- THE ABILITY OF
EMPLOYERS TO ANTICIPATE WHAT'S
GOING ON IN THERE -- EFFORTS --
I'D LIKE YOU TO RESPOND TO THAT
BECAUSE I CAN'T.
I CAN'T FIGURE THAT ONE OUT
MYSELF -- AND ALSO OF RESPOND TO
THE CLAIM.
I ALWAYS FIND SO INTERESTING
THAT EMPLOYEES ARE WELL
PROTECTED BY.
THE RIGHT. TO TO SUE AND HAVE
THEIR DAY IN COURT IS IS
PROMISED UNDER WHAT I HAS AT
LEAST AS I READ THE CONSTITUTION.
COULD YOU RESPOND TO THOSE TWO
ISSUES SURE -- FIRST I IT'S HARD.
TO IN SOME WAYS DRESSED ME -- TO
EXPLAIN THE OPPOSITION'S
IRRATIONAL OPPOSITION AS I SEE
IT I'M FROM A WORKER ADVOCATE
POSITION.
AT I UNDERSTAND AS
REPRESENTATIVES OF BUSINESS --
YA THEY PREFER ARBITRATION --
IT'S SECRETIVE THERE'S NO
APPEALS PROCESS ITS FINAL -- WE
DON'T KNOW IF THINGS COME OUT
FAIRLY IF THERE'S A
MISAPPLICATION OF LAW THERE'S NO
WAY TO APPEAL THAT -- SO TERE
IS CERTAINTY FOR THE EMPLOYER
ABSOLUTELY -- BUT AT THE COST OF
WHAT AT THE COST OF THE PUBLIC
POLICY THAT WE PUT FORWARD IN
THIS BUILDING AND PROMOTED AS
WHAT WE WANT FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA -- YOU CANNOT COMPARE
UNION COLLECTIVE BARGAINING ART
ARBITRATION I'M WITH AN
INDIVIDUAL WORKER YOU KNOW
ANYTIME ARBITRATION MADE WORK
WELL.
WHEN YOU HAVE A EQUALS AND WHO
CAN VOLUNTARILY ENTER INTO
SOMETHING AND HAVE -- UNMEDIATED
DISCUSSION BASICALLY ABOUT ABOUT
WHERE THINGS SHOULD GO AND
EVERYBODY HAS EQUAL RESOURCES IN
FIGHTING THAT.
THAT IS A MUCH DIFFERENT
SITUATION THAN YOU HAVE AN
INDIVIDUAL WORKER AND THE
WORKERS WERE TALKING ABOUT
BUYING FAR -- MANY OF THEM DON'T
SPEAK ENGLISH -- MANY OF THEM
ARE IMMIGRANTS LOW WAGE WORKERS
WHO WHO MAY NOT HAVE FORMAL
EDUCATION DEFINITELY ARE NOT
ATTORNEYS -- AND WHO ARE LEFT TO
FEND FOR THEMSELVES IN A
SECRETIVE PROCESS -- IF THE
EMPLOYERS ARE CORRECT AND AND
BELIEVE THAT THIS IS SO MUCH
BETTER FOR THE WORKER.
AT THE EIGHT UNDER THIS BILL
WOULD HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
EXPLAIN THAT TO THE WORKER AND
GIVE THEM THAT INFORMATION PRIOR
TO ASKING BEEN SIGNED
ARBITRATION AGREEMENT.
THAT MAKE CREE ANOTHER PROBLEM I
SEE COMMON BUT THEY DO IT WOULD
HAVE THAT RIGHT -- AND IT WOULD
BE THE WORKERS CHOICE THAN TO
DECIDE IF THEY WOULD LIKE TO
SIGN AN ARBITRATION AGREEMENT --
IT WOULDN'T TAKE AWAY THE THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR ARBITRATION IF
BOTH THE WORKER AND THE EMPLOYER
DECIDED THAT'S THE BEST ROUTE
HOWEVER -- WE KNOW THAT THE
CONSTITUTION DOES GIVE
INDIVIDUALS A RIGHT.
TO REDRESS IN COURT SYSTEM IT'S
AMAZING TO ME THAT THE COURT
SYSTEM ITSELF IS TRYING TO TAKE
THAT AWAY ARE ALLOWING -- SO
MANY BIG CORPORATIONS TAKE THAT
RATE FROM INDIVIDUALS I'M I I
THINK THAT'S SCARY I A I THINK
THAT THAT TWEET WE NEED TO LOOK
AT THAT AND AS FAR AS THE
ANTICIPATION OF OF LARGE
SETTLEMENTS I WOULD SUGGEST THAT
EMPLOYERS SHOULD FOLLOW THE LAW --
AND AND THEN PERHAPS FOLLOW ALL
THE LAWS WE SET OUT IN AND
PERHAPS THEN THEY DON'T NEED TO
ANTICIPATE -- HUGE SETTLEMENTS
AGAINST I'M I MEAN I I THINK
WE'RE PRETTY CLEAR ON
REQUIREMENTS -- FOR EMPLOYERS
YES THERE CAN BE SOME PROBLEMS
AND AND WE DEAL WITH THOSE --
BUT FOR THE MOST PART IF YOU RUN
A BUSINESS RESPONSIBLY AND YOU
ARE CLEARLY FOLLOWING THE LAW --
YOU DON'T GET AN ANTICIPATED
HUGE SETTLEMENTS AGAINST YOU --
THAT THAT'S WHY WE HAVE LAWS --
SO THAT THAT TO ME SEEMS A
LITTLE -- AN EASY.
AS FAR AS WHETHER OR NOT THIS IS
GOING TO BE CHALLENGED -- I WILL
POINT OUT THAT LAST YEAR AND I
BELIEVE THIS YEAR AS WELL AND I
HAVE TO GO CHECK SINCE I
OBVIOUSLY DIDN'T SEND OUT CO
AUTHOR FORMS -- THAT THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL SUPPORTS THIS
SO THE THE INDIVIDUAL WHO WOULD%
BE TASKED WITH DEFENDING IN --
THIS BILL.
AT ARGUED IN ALL OF THESE CASES
IN AN IN HAS BEEN AT THE
FOREFRONT IN THE COURT.
ON THESE -- CASES IN THE PAST
AND TOOK ALL OF THE DISCUSSION
AND ALL THE ANALYSIS OF WHAT --
THE JUDGE'S DECISION WAS TO HELP
US CRAFT A BILL THAT HE THINKS
AND WE THINK CAN STAND UP TO
JUDICIAL SCRUTINY -- WILL
SOMEBODY SO ABSOLUTELY THAT'S
WHAT HAPPENS BUT DO WE AS
CALIFORNIANS BELIEVE THAT
WORKERS SHOULD HAVE THE
AVAILABILITY TO PURSUE THEIR
CLAIMS -- IT VOLUNTARILY THROUGH
A VARIETY OF SOURCES INCLUDING A
LABOR COMMISSIONER WHERE THERE
IS NO NEED FOR AN ATTORNEY -- IN
COURT BECAUSE MAYBE SOMETHING IS
SO -- BROAD THAT YOU KNOW
AFFECTING SO MANY WORKERS IN A
CERTAIN -- INDUSTRY OR OR SO
IMPORTANT THAT IT'S A PUBLIC
POLICY ISSUE THAT NEEDS TO BE
BROUGHT OUT IN PUBLIC AND WE SAW
THAT A LOT WITH WITH THE SEXUAL
HARASSMENT.
AND ASSAULT IN THE WORKPLACE
THAT WE WE'VE SEEN IN SOME THESE
LOW WAGE -- JOBS AT OR IF THEY
PREFER TO HANDLE SOMETHING AND
IN ARBITRATION I MEAN THE WORKER
THEMSELVES SHOULD HAVE THOSE
OPTIONS AVAILABLE TO THEM AND
SHOULDN'T SAY.
UNLESS YOU'RE WILLING TO GIVE UP
ALL THESE RIGHTS -- YOU CAN'T
HELP THE STOP AND THAT'S ALL
WE'RE TRYING TO STOP IN I'M
MIGHT IF I COULD ADD TO THIS
[inaudible]
OF CONCEPT WAS DESIGNED BETWEEN
TWO TO BE AVAILABLE TO
BUSINESSES.
WHO MIGHT PREFERRED TO GO
THROUGH A MORE EXPEDITIOUS
PROCESS IN?
REACHING RESOLUTION OF DISPUTES
THAT THEY WERE HAVING WITH OTHER
BUSINESSES OF EQUAL STATURE IN
AN EQUAL -- FINANCIAL -- THE
QUALITY IF YOU WILL AND AS WE'VE
SEEN I THINK -- THE THE THE ACT
THE FEDERAL ACT BEING REALLY
SUBVERTED BECAUSE IF I'M NOT
MISTAKEN WHEN IT WAS INITIALLY
PASSED THAT WAS THE FOCUS.
ON THE ABILITY OF BUSINESSES WHO
WERE IN DISPUTE WITH EACH OTHER
TO COME UP WITH RESOLUTION AT
THE IN AN EARLIER.
STAGE SO.
I VERY MUCH WOULD LIKE TO BE A
CO AUTHOR I I REALLY BELIEVE
THAT THIS LAW HAS BEEN --
MISAPPLIED.
THE SUPREME COURT TO SUPREME
COURT I YOU KNOW AM HUMBLED BY.
THEIR POWER.
I STILL THINK THE WRONG -- AND I
THINK THE MORE THEY KEEP PUSHING
THIS THE MORE IT UNDERMINES AND
SUBVERTS WHAT I THINK WAS A VERY
WELL INTENDED EFFORT. TO GIVE
OPTIONS AND THERE ARE
ARBITRATION.
ARBITRATORS WHO DO A WONDERFUL
JOB.
BUT THE SYSTEM HAS SUCH A THUMB
ON THE SCALE OF THE QUALITY OF A
JUSTICE FOR BOTH SIDES IN THIS
CASE IN PARTICULAR WITH
EMPLOYERS AND WITH SOME OF THE
OTHER THINGS THAT WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT SO.
I COMMEND YOU FOR THIS AND IF
THIS IS A CASE THAT WILL GO UP
TO THE COURTS SO BE IT BUT AGAIN.
IF THIS IS ALSO SOMETHING THAT
IF WE GET A CONGRESS THAT
ACTUALLY CARES ABOUT CONSUMERS
AND AND EMPLOYEES MIGHT TAKE
ANOTHER LOOK AT THIS LAW ON A
FEDERAL BASIS I FRANKLY THINK IT
WOULD BE INCUMBENT UPON US TO
HELP LEAD AS CALIFORNIA DOES SO
OFTEN.
IN TRYING TO ESTABLISH WHAT ARE
THE TRUE VALUES OF THE SOCIETY
AND SO WITH THAT I WOULD MOVE
THE BILL AND ASKED TO BE A CO
AUTHOR.
THANK YOU SENATOR JACKSON AND
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
RESPECT LAST WHEN I THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND AND MAY I THINK
THIS IS A THAT TO SALUTE YOU FOR
DOING THIS AND BRING IT TO ME I
I THINK.
NO ONE SHOULD HAVE A PROBLEM
WITH ARBITRATION BUT THE SHOULD
BE CONSENT.
OR A OR YOUR INTO THE PROBLEMS
OF THAT WE'VE SEEN SO THANK YOU
FOR DOING THAT WE DO HAVE A
MOTION FROM SENATOR JACKSON'S --
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
JUDICIARY.
SENATOR HILL HI CAM HILL AYE
MORRELL.
WORLDNOW JACKSON.
HI.
JACKSON AYE MITCHELL.
PAN.
THE BILL HAS TO GO TO HOLD THE
ROLE OPEN THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SALAS GOOD
MORNING.
AND I FAILED TO MENTION EARLIER
WHAT WE WILL BE DOING IN THE
COMMITTEE TODAY JUST AS WE DID
LAST WEEK.
WE WILL ALLOW FIVE MINUTES OF
TESTIMONY FOR SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION AND THEN.
ALLOWED MOVE FORWARD WITH THE ME
TOO FROM THERE FORWARD SOME
RUMORS OUT GOOD MORNING AB. ONE
TO ME AB TWO OR THREE ITEM
NUMBER TWO ON OUR AGENDA PLEASE
PROCEED ALL RIGHT THANK WAS
CHAIR MEMBERS -- THANKS FOR
LETTING ME PRESENT THIS BILL
DEALS WITH VALLEY FEVER I THINK
I SPOKE TO ALMOST EVERYONE IN
THE LEGISLATURE ABOUT THIS LAST
YEAR'S.
THIS IS THE THE FOURTH BILL THE
PACKAGE THAT WE HAD THREE GOT
SIGNED LAST YEAR -- WE KNOW
VALLEY FEVER IS ENDEMIC CERTAIN
AREAS OF THE STATE WE KNOW.
A HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
CASES GO UNREPORTED EVERY SINGLE
YEAR AND WE ALSO KNOW JUST BASED
OFF OF REPORTING.
THAT ISN'T EVEN WITH THE RECENT --
WILD FIRES UP NORTH BUT ALSO
LIKE INVENTOR ACCOUNTING WE SEEN
SPIKE'S.
OF VALLEY FEVER CASES AFTER THE
FIRES BECAUSE OF THE SPORES
BEING MOVED -- IN THE GROUND SO
THIS BILL IS ACTUALLY DESIGNED
TO HELP WORKERS THAT ARE OUT --
WORKING IN THOSE SENSITIVE SITES
AND JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
GOOD THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING GOOD MORNING.
MY NAME IS PAULA MASSEY IN FROM
HANFORD CALIFORNIA AND I'M HERE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL -- I
HAVE TWO SONS MY OLDEST ONE
PASSED AWAY FROM VALLEY FEVER
AND I LIKE TO SHARE SOME.
SOME PIGEONS WITH.
OF HIM [inaudible]
BEFORE -- THE MIDDLE ONE IS WHEN
HE HAD HIS LITTLE A SEIZURE AND
OCTOBER EIGHTH TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN AND NEVER CAME HOME.
IN THE LAST PAGES WHEN HE WENT
TO HEINZ HOSPICE AND FRESNO -- I
DO SUPPORT THIS BECAUSE THERE
NEEDS TO BE EDUCATION AND
AWARENESS.
WHEN HE WAS?
IT'S GOT SICK IN.
TWO THOUSAND TEN THEY TOLD HIM
THAT HE HAD A LUNG INFECTION
FIRST WITH PNEUMONIA.
THEN WITH A LONG INFECTION.
HE WASN'T DIAGNOSED UNTIL TWO
YEARS LATER.
WITH VALLEY FEVER AT THAT TIME
WAS LIVING IN PHOENIX SO FEW
MONTHS LATER I CAME BACK HOME.
TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN HE STARTED
HAVING SEIZURES THE VALLEY FEVER
THE SPORT THEY GOT INTO HIS BODY
AND STARTED SPREADING TO WHAT IS
BEHIND.
IN HIS BRAIN.
IN THE PLEDGE THAT TO SEE HIS
BRAIN STOPPED WORKING -- I HAVE
SECOND SON.
HE HAS VALLEY FEVER.
AND HAD WE KNOWN ABOUT THIS WE
WOULD HAVE BEEN ABLE TO DO
THINGS ABOUT IT MY SENSE WOULD
HAVE NEVER BEEN PLAYING ON BASE.
IN JACK RABBIT FEEL.
FILLING DIRT BOMBS AT EACH OTHER --
MAYBE MY OLDEST SON WOULD NEVER
WENT TO WORK AT A OF A COMPANY
THAT DEALS WITH FARMING.
IN THE COURT FEELS.
I'VE BEEN TESTED.
IT'S IN MY SYSTEM.
BUTIT'S NOT ACTIVE ACCORDING TO
THEM THE DOCTORS.
IN MY LOCAL AREA.
BUT I DO HAVE SYMPTOMS.
SO I AM FOR THIS AND I DO A LOT
ADVOCATING IN MY COMMUNITY.
TALKING TO DIFFERENT GROUPS AND
TELLING THEM GET TESTED AND IF
YOUR DOCTOR WILL TEST YOU GO TO
THE HEALTH DEPARTMENT.
MY SECOND SON HIS DOCTOR WOULD
NOT TEST THEM.
BECAUSE HE SAID HE DIDN'T HAVE
SYMPTOMS.
BUT HIS GIRLFRIEND MAKE SURE
THAT HE WENT TO HIS OLD DR.
SHE TALKED TO HIM THE CIVIL
TESTIMONY CAME BACK POSITIVE.
RIGHT NOW MY SON CAN'T WORK.
IS A LOT OF PAIN HE CAN'T SLEEP.
SOMETIMES HE HAS NO APPETITE TO
EAT.
SO I AM FOR THIS BILL I AM.
FOR EDUCATION.
I MEANT FOR EMPLOYERS AND
EMPLOYEES IN MY COMMUNITY I HAVE
MANY PEOPLE COME OUT CUTTING
GRASS BLOWING STUFF.
IN THERE NO MASK.
THERE'S NOTHING TO PROTECT THEM.
I'VE TALKED TO PEOPLE WHO HAVE
WORKED IN THE FIELDS WITH A
DOING THE SOLAR PANELS.
AND THEY'RE SIGNING A WAIVER.
THAT IF THEY GET VALLEY FEVER.
THIS IS NO GUARANTEE THAT YOU
GOT A FROM THIS JOB.
THAT'S NOT ACCEPTABLE.
OKAY SO I AM.
I AM PRO FOR THIS THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR BEING
HERE SO SORRY FOR THE OTHERS IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN TOM
SHE TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
LANDSCAPE CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
OR THREE WE REALLY APPRECIATE
THE WORK OF THE AUTHOR ON THIS
MEASURE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
JUDICIARY.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE OUT
RUBBER MATURE ENOUGH THE CAL
CHAMBER IN STRONG SUPPORT AND
I'M GLAD TO IMPROVE THIS.
SHE THAT THANK YOU.
JAMIE CON ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATED GENERAL CONTRACTORS
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK
YOU IS KIND.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANYONE HERE IN
OPPOSITION.
GOOD.
OF THANK YOU IN BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE CHAIR JUST SAW ON
BEHALF OF OUR FORMER COLLEAGUE
JEAN FULLER WHO LOST HER SISTER.
TO THIS DREADED DISEASE THAT
HAPPY TO MOVE THE BILL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THAT IT'S IT'S A
BUT YES ENERGY I HAVE A QUESTION
AND YES YOU'RE RIGHT THIS IS
SHOWING UP NOT ONLY IN VENTURA
THROUGH THE FIRE BUT AFTER THE
DEBRIS FLOW.
A MUD SLIDE IN SANTA BARBARA
THAT.
WE'RE SEEING THIS.
IF SOMEONE IS TESTED IS THERE
TREATMENT AVAILABLE THAT CAN
EITHER REDUCE OR CURE OR YOU
KNOW ASSIST IN.
RESOLVING THIS DISEASE SO THAT
PEOPLE CAN GO ON TO LIVE HEALTHY
IN LONG LIVES SO CURRENTLY THERE
IS A NO VACCINE OR CURE FOR
VALLEY FEVER -- IN LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET -- THROUGH THE GRACES OF
EVERYBODY HERE WE WERE ABLE TO
INCLUDE SOME MONEY.
FOR FUNDING WHICH IS NOW GOING
TO THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
TO ACTUALLY RESEARCH TRY.
TO GET US TO A PLACE WHERE WE
CAN GET TO POSSIBLY A VACCINE
AND A CURE -- BUT THAT'S YOU
KNOW SMALL DROP IN THE BUCKET
AND HOPEFULLY WE CAN CONTINUE
THAT FIGHT A NO FEDERALLY
THEY'RE ALSO LOOKING AT THIS AS
WELL -- ALL IT'S VERY ENDEMIC TO
THE ENTIRE SOUTHWEST.
OF THE UNITED STATES SO YOU SEE
A LOT OF NUMBERS AND YOU MEXICO.
ARIZONA HAS A LOT OF MY NUMBERS
TAXES OBVIOUSLY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WE DID THE RESEARCH.
OF THE EXCUSE ME OF THE HUNDRED
AND FIFTY THOUSAND UNREPORTED
CASES WE FOUND FIFTY OUT OF THE
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES IT WAS
CASES AND FIFTY OF COUNTIES.
IN CALIFORNIA AND SO THAT'S WHY
WE'VE BEEN MOVING THIS.
WE WERE FORTUNATE THAT THE
GOVERNOR SIGNED THREE PIECES OF
LEGISLATION LAST YEAR THIS IS
THE FOURTH PIECE -- THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO GET THAT FOR WORKERS
HAVE CAL OSHA STEP IN.
A LOT OF TIMES WE FIND TO FOR
INSTANCE LIKE IT WAS MENTIONED
EARLIER FROM PAULA.
IS THERE WAS A CREW OUT IN SAN
LUIS OBISPO COUNTY THAT WAS
INSTALLING SOLAR PANELS.
AND EVERYBODY ON THE CREW CAME
DOWN WITH VALLEY FEVER.
AND YOU ASK WHAT COULD WE HAVE
DONE TO PREVENT SOMETHING LIKE
THAT ESPECIALLY THESE ENDEMIC
AREAS.
AND SAID YOU KNOW IT'S PUTTING
ON A AND NINETY FIVE TO MASK.
YOU KNOW IF YOU HAVE AN IN
NINETY FIVE MASS THAT WOULD HAVE
HELPED.
SO MAYBE WE CAN GET CAL OSHA TO
SET THE STANDARDS ESPECIALLY
THESE HIGHLY ENDEMIC AREAS TO
HOPEFULLY PREVENT PEOPLE.
FROM GETTING BALLOT ARE THERE
TREATMENTS THOUGH IF IF IF WE
CAN PEOPLE ARE EDUCATED THEY GET
TESTED THEY FIND THEY HAVEN'T
WHAT CAN WE DO TO ASSIST THEM.
YEAH SO THERE'S A THERE THERE'S
SOME MEDICATION THAT THEY CAN'T
TAKE EVERYONE'S RESPONDING
DIFFERENTLY TO IT AND I THINK
pCOMING IN.
BECAUSE I KNOW -- SOME OF THE
RESEARCH IS LOOKING AT GENETIC
MARKERS BECAUSE IT'S ACTUALLY
MORE PREVALENT.
AND AND SOME ETHNICITIES AND
OTHERS -- AFRICAN AMERICAN IS
ONE OF THEM [inaudible]
AND AND SO THE RESEARCH RIGHT
NOW.
I'M MORE THAN HAPPY TO SHARE
THIS I WOULD I WAS JUST AT UCSF --
TWO WEEKENDS AGO -- ACTUALLY
DISCUSSING SOME OF THE RESEARCH
THAT THEY'RE DOING THEIR UC
MERCED IS ANOTHER ONE UNIVERSITY
OF ARIZONA.
I WITH DOCTOR GALGIANI IS
ANOTHER ONE IS ACTUALLY RELATED
TO OUR SENATOR GALGIANI.
THANK YOU MAN THANK YOU SIR OKAY.
THANK YOU CENTER EXHAUST FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD AND
ABOUT HE WAS ACTUALLY FUNGAL
INFECTION AND FUNGAL INFECTIONS
ARE VERY DIFFICULT TO TREAT --
THE MEDICATIONS OFTEN HAS TO
MAKE SIGNIFICANT SIDE EFFECTS --
AND AND TENSION IS AS THE
BRIGHTON OFFICE ONLY WE NEED TO
TRY TO WORK ON TREATMENTS AND
CURES -- BUT FUNGAL INFECTIONS
IN GENERAL OR IS IT EXTREMELY
DIFFICULT TO TREAT AND OFTEN AND
SAID -- THE TREATMENTS AND CELLS
ARE VERY DIFFICULT WE DO NEED
MORE RESEARCH THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP -- WE THAT THAT
PREVENTION PART IS A VERY
IMPORTANT -- I I SHOULD MENTION
THAT IF YOU'VE NEVER WORN AND
PROPERLY FITTED AND NINETY FIVE
MASK.
YOU DON'T REALIZE HOW DIFFICULT
IS ACTUALLY TO WORK WEARING ONE
FOR AN EXCESSIVE AMOUNT OF TIME --
SO WE REALLY GOT THINK ABOUT
RIGHTY OF MITIGATION APPROACHES
AND CERTAINLY THINK THE RATE
THAT HAVE CAL OSHA LOOK AT THAT
FOR CLIMATE CHANGE UNFORTUNATELY
IS ALSO CHANGING THE AREAS RIGHT
BECAUSE IT'S A SORT OF A CLIMATE
THAT THE FUNGUS THRIVES IN.
AND SO THAT IS POTENTIALLY
EXPANDING THE AREAS IN WHICH
THIS FONG I COULD SPREAD AND BE
ENDEMIC IN THE SOIL SOMETHING WE
NEED TO BE CONCERNED ABOUT AS
WELL.
AND CERTAINLY -- I APPRECIATE --
THAT WE'VE INVESTED SOME OF OUR
STATE FUNDS IN TRYING TO ADDRESS
THIS ISSUE AND RAISE AWARENESS I
THINK IT'S THE OTHER THING I
HEARD FROM THE WITNESS LIKE WITH
THE DOCTORS AND PUBLIC HEALTH
FOLKS IN THE NURSES NEED TO KNOW
THEY NEED TO BE THINKING ABOUT
VALLEY FEVER IT'S NOT.
ALWAYS NO OBVIOUS THAT'S NOT
LIKE IF SOMEONE COMES IN THE
VALLEY FEVER RIGHT INTO IT'S A
THE SYMPTOMS ARE -- SOMEWHAT --
INITIALLY INITIALLY SOMEWHAT
AMBIGUOUS AND THE PROBLEM IS
THEN WHEN YOU GET REALLY SICK --
THAN YOU KNOW AND BUT THEN IT'S
THE RATHER LATE SO THANKS SO
MUCH RINGS BILL FOR BE HAPPY TO
MOVE IT TO PRODUCE THANK YOU
THANK YOU SENATOR PAN AND AND I
IN THAT FIGHT YOU'VE NOT STOPPED
SINCE THE MINUTE YOU GOTTEN INTO
THIS BUILDING AND IT'S MUCH
APPRECIATED.
BECAUSE WE HAVE TO HAVE A SAFE
WORKPLACE AND AND IT'S OUR DUTY
TO DO THAT AND PROVIDE THAT --
HAVE YOU CONSIDERED LOOKING AT
THE PERHAPS WHEN PROVIDING THE
TRAINING OR THE MATERIALS IN THE
LANGUAGES THAT MAY BE SPECIFIC.
PEOPLE PERHAPS YOU COULD LOOK AT
THAT YES NO WE DID AND WE
ACTUALLY HAD A SEPARATE PIECE OF
UNFORTUNATELY TO ACTUALLY EXPAND --
THE DIFFERENT LANGUAGES FOR A
LOT OF DIFFERENT THINGS SO WE
HAVE WE HAVE LOOKED AT THAT BUT
MORE THAN HAPPY TO SIT WITH THE
STAKEHOLDERS AND SEE WHAT WE CAN.
WE CAN DO TO DEVELOP MORE.
OF WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE AT NOT
JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NAY
VOTER APPRECIATE EVERYONE'S
SUPPORT -- ABOUT THIS VERY
IMPORTANT MEASURE THAT'S
AFFECTING A LOT OF FOLKS --
INCLUDING PEOPLE HERE IN OUR
BUILDING.
RIGHT -- WITH SENATOR FULLER BUT
ALSO WITH THE SIMPLY MEMBER
GRAYSON WHO ACTUALLY CONTRACTED
VALLEY FEVER AND HE TALKS ABOUT
WHAT DOCTOR PANELS TALKING ABOUT.
THE MISDIAGNOSIS WHERE PEOPLE
THOUGHT IT WAS THE FLU OR OR A
COMMON COLD AND SO HE GETS
ANTIBIOTICS WHICH DO NOTHING
BECAUSE IT'S A FUNGAL DISEASE.
AND SO -- YOU KNOW PEOPLE ARE
ACTUALLY SUFFERING IN YOU KNOW I
APPRECIATE -- THE THE
COMMITTEE'S INDULGENCE ON THIS
MEASURE IN JUST A RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR IT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE DO HAVE A MOTION FROM SENATOR
PAN.
TO OF THE BEST TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE PLEASE CALL.
SENATOR HILL AYE HILL AYE
MORRELL HI.
MORRELL AYE JACKSON.
JACKSON AYE MITCHELL.
HI MITCHELL AYE PAN BY AND BY
THE BILL HAS FIVE VOTES IT'S OUT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND I DO SEE CENTER THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JONES JONES SAWYER THERE.
GOOD MORNING ITEM NUMBER SEVEN
HEY AB.
TEN OH SEVEN WELCOME.
NICE TO SEE YOU THIS MORNING
GOOD MORNING.
WE APPRECIATE ASSEMBLY MEMBER MY
SENATORS HERE TO GET ME DRUNK I
KNOW I ME TO START [inaudible]
BE CAREFUL.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS.
I WON THE FIRST US START BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE.
AMENDMENTS AND THANK YOU TO
CHAIR A COMMITTEE -- FOR THEIR
HARD WORK ON THIS BILL.
AB. TEN OH SEVEN HELPS OUR STATE
EMPLOYEES BY PROVIDING.
A CERTAINTY.
IN THE DISCIPLINARY TIMELINE
EXISTING LAW ALLOWS UP TO THREE
YEARS TO COMPLETE AN
INVESTIGATION THAT MAY RESULT IN
RE EMPLOYED DISCIPLINE.
THIS MEANS THAT A STATE EMPLOYEE
AND OR MANAGEMENT MUST PUT THEIR
CAREER AND THE DISPLAY --
PROCESS ON HOLD FOR UP TO THREE
YEARS -- IN ADDITION EMPLOYEES
CANNOT RECEIVE A RAISE A REQUEST
TO TRANSFER OR PUT FORWARD FOR
PROMOTION.
IN THE MEANTIME -- THE EXISTING
EMPLOYEES COULD REPEAT THE SAME
INFRACTION ALL OVER AGAIN START
THE PROCESS AGAIN AND AGAIN.
REDUCING THE TIME NECESSARY TO
DISCIPLINE A STATE EMPLOYEE TO
ONE YEAR PROVIDES EMPLOYEE AND
MANAGEMENT CERTAINTY ALLOW FOR
MORE TIMELY CORRECTIVE ACTION.
WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY IS JOHN
LEVEL REPEATING THE STATE
CORRECTIONAL SUPERVISOR SPONSORS
OF THE BILLS -- MEMBER I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
BOTH OF WHICH I GUESS SOMEONE
ELSE HERE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF IT --
JOHN LEVEL O BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONAL
SUPERVISORS ORGANIZATION AS
MISTER JONES SAWYER POINTS OUT
WE ARE THE SPONSORS OF THIS BILL.
AS A MATTER OF SIMPLE JUSTICE OF
THE HUMAN CONDITION BEING WHAT
IT IS UNDER CURRENT LAW YOU HAVE
THREE YEARS -- AND PEOPLE WAIT
AND WAIT AND WAIT AND SO THE
EMPLOYEES CAREER.
IS FROZEN -- HERE SHE IS
ASSIGNED SOMEPLACE WITH THEIR
FROZEN THEY CAN'T -- THEY CAN'T
PROMOTE THEY CAN'T LATERALLY
TRANSLATE.
OF MR NOT THREE YEARS ARE UP.
AND THERE'S A DETERMINATION NO
FAULT BY THE EMPLOYER A BY THE
EMPLOYEE WELL BUT GUESS WHAT
THAT EMPLOYEE HAS BEEN HERE
RETRIEVAL BILLY PENALIZED FOR
THREE YEARS.
USING HER CAREER HAS BEEN FROZEN
THIS BILL IS A MATTER SIMPLE
JUSTICE.
WE SPONSOR THIS BILL WE COMMAND.
MISTER JONES SAWYER FOR HAVING
FOUGHT THIS BATTLE FOR MANY
YEARS AND IT'S JUST LONG OVERDUE
THAT -- THAT THE ADDRESS THIS.
PLEASE SIR THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR LEVEL OF OTHERS IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
TO BAKER WITH HER IN REDUCES HIS
FOR THE PROFESSIONAL ENGINEERS
IN CALIFORNIA GOVERNMENT SUPPORT.
THANK YOU TO BAKER APPRECIATED --
OTHERS IN SUPPORT IS THERE
ANYONE HERE IN OPPOSITION.
PLEASE SEE NO ONE VERY GOOD WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
SENATOR JACKSON'S TO QUICK
QUESTION -- I I HEAR YOU AND AND
CREATED THREE YEARS WHETHER THE
PERSON IS AT FAULT OR YOU KNOW
IS VIOLATED SOME.
WOMEN CONDITION NOT WHY THREE
YEARS IT SEEMS LIKE SUCH AN
EXTRAORDINARY AMOUNT OF TIME IN
YOUR IN YOUR FIRST THE FIRST
PART OF THE BILL YOU REDUCE FROM --
THREE THREE YEARS AFTER THE
OCCURRENCE OF THE PRECIPITATING
EVENT TO ONE YEAR AFTER
DISCOVERY.
OF THE EVENT AND THEN.
YOU HAVE A THREE YEAR TIME LIMIT
FOR THE MORE SUBSTANTIAL CASES
WHY CAN'T THIS GET DONE WITHIN A
YEAR PERIOD OF TIME SO THE
RESOLUTION.
IS IS EFFECTIVE FOR EVERYONE
WHETHER THAT PERSON IS
VINDICATED OR WHETHER OR NOT
THEY'RE FOUND LIABLE I MEAN.
THREE YEARS AS AN AWFULLY LONG
TIME TO BE GOING THROUGH THIS
PROCESS IS OR SOME EXPLANATION
AS TO WHY IT TAKES THREE YEARS
THAT'S THE REASON FOR THE BILL
THERE ISN'T -- THE LAW ALL RIGHT
NOW IS THREE YEARS FOR ALL STATE
EMPLOYEES SO GUESS WHAT YOUR
THERE'S THERE'S SOME NAY
QUESTION ABOUT YOUR CONDUCT IN.
YOUR BACK FOR YEARS.
OVERALL ONE YEAR PERIOD EIGHT
INCLUDING EVERY [inaudible]
HOST.
UNDER THE BILL ONE YEAR FROM
DISCOVERY RIGHT -- AND THAT
MAKES SENSE BECAUSE THAT'S A
TIME WHEN YOU CAN DO.
ANY KIND OF INVESTIGATION AND
FRANKLY PEOPLES -- RECOLLECTIONS
REMAIN INVOICE LONGER TO OVER
THREE YEARS PEOPLE RETIRED THEY
MOVE -- SOME PASS ON TO ANOTHER
WORLD -- AND ALL OF THIS IS LOST
IN THE EMPLOYEE IS IRRETRIEVABLY
PENALIZE SO BASICALLY THIS IS
ONE YEAR ACROSS THE BOARD FROM
TIME TO DISCOVER YOUR RESPECTIVE
OF THE WITH WITH SOME EXCEPTIONS.
WHERE YOU HAVE EMBEZZLEMENT
WHERE YOU HAVE CERTAIN SEXUAL
HARASSMENT ISSUES WHERE WHERE
YOU HAVE ROBLEMS OF PEOPLE
COMING FORWARD AND DISCOVERY?
SO THERE ARE SOME CARVED
EXCEPTIONS BUT WITH THIS.
BILL DOES IS IT.
IT TAKES.
THE GENERAL RULE WILL NOW BE ONE
YEAR.
WHICH OF PARALLELS WHAT HAPPENS
WITH PEACE OFFICERS NOW FOR
EXAMPLE RIGHT MY CONCERN THOUGH
IS IF THERE'S AN ALLEGATION OF
SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
IT'S THREE YEARS FROM THE TIME
OF DISCOVER YOU THEY STILL GET
THREE YEARS TO INVESTIGATE ONCE
IT'S THE MATTERS BEEN BROUGHT TO
THEM.
THAT SEEMS LIKE A HECK OF A LONG
TIME IF YOU'RE THE VICTIM OF THE
SEXUAL HARASSMENT OR IF YOU ARE
THE ACCUSED THREE YEARS -- YOU
KNOW WAS THE VICTIM LET'S SAY
IT'S AN ACCURATE IT'S INACCURATE
ALLEGATIONS.
DOES THE VICTIM THEN HAVE TO
SPEND THREE YEARS WITH YOU IN IT
AT WORK OR IF IT ISN'T AN
ACCURATE ONE DO YOU HAVE TO WAIT
THREE YEARS FOR YOUR VINDICATION
A WHITE THE PURPOSE.
OF THAT EXCEPTION.
IS BECAUSE WE WHAT WE ARE
LEARNING IS.
THERE IS A RELUCTANCE OF PEOPLE
TO COME FORWARD OVER TIME YOU
HAVE ONE INSTANCE AND THEN LO
AND BEHOLD MAYBE TO RETURN ON
AND I UNDERSTAND THAT BUT IT IS
IT IS IT THREE YEARS FROM THE
TIME THAT THE THAT BEARD ADAM
DISCOVERY.
FROM DISCOVERY OR FROM REPORT SO
THREE YEARS FROM THE TIME THAT
THE THAT THE THAT THE ENTITY THE
INVESTIGATING ENTITY RECEIVES
THAT INFORMATION.
BUT THAT HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
RELUCTANCE TO COME FORWARD IF
SOMEBODY COMES FORWARD WHY ISN'T
IT ONE YEAR FROM THE TIME THAT
THEY COME FORWARD WELL BECAUSE
THE THREE YEARS WE'VE MADE THE
RELUCTANCE.
MAY ACTUALLY.
ASSIST WITH FILLING OUT.
THAT MAYBE THERE'S ONLY ONE
ALLEGATION BUT MAY BE OVER A
THREE YEAR PERIOD YES YOU DO
HAVE OTHER PEOPLE WHO CAME
FORWARD BECAUSE THEY WERE
RELUCTANT TO TO BEGIN WITH
THAT'S AN EXCEPTION.
THAT'S ONE EXCEPTION THAT WE ARE
CARVING -- IN THE BILL BUT THE
GENERAL RULE NINETY IS GOING TO
BE IS GOING TO BE ONE YEAR.
IF BUT IF WE'RE TRYING TO
ENFORCE -- IN THE WORKPLACE A
HARASSMENT FREE ENVIRONMENT.
WHICH AT AND WE WANT PEOPLE TO
COME FORWARD IF THEY COME
FORWARD.
THEY STILL MAY HAVE TO WAIT
THREE YEARS FOR SOME KIND OF
RESOLUTION. TO THAT CLAIM.
BOTH AGAIN AS A PROPOSED A
VICTIM OR IS A PORTED
PERPETRATOR WHO -- DON'T TURN --
WHO?
ONCE RESOLUTION OF THIS WHY DO
WE GIVE THREE YEARS IN THESE
KINDS OF CIRCUMSTANCES I I I
JUST THINK THAT IF WE REALLY ARE
SERIOUS ABOUT.
EXTRACTING THIS FROM THE
WORKPLACE TO GIVE THREE YEARS
FOR AN INVESTIGATION SEEMS LIKE
A AN AWFULLY LONG PERIOD OF TIME.
PAUL KIRBY HAVE CORRECTIONAL
SUPERVISORS ASSOCIATION UP MA'AM
WHAT HAPPENS IN IF IT'S A SEXUAL
HARASSMENT CASE YOUR CONCERN IS
TO HAVING THE VICTIM STILL BE IN.
CLOSE PROXIMITY OF THE SUSPECT
OF THE HARASSMENT OF BEHAVIOR
ONCE IT'S DISCOVERED ON THE
FIRST TIME THAT PERSON WILL BE
MOVED TO HIT THAT THAT'S A
NORMAL PROCESS THEY WILL MOVE
THEM OUT.
SO THE FACT THAT IT TAKES LONGER
TO INVESTIGATE THESE TYPES OF
CASES BECAUSE THERE'S A LOT OF
ON REPORTING AND AND RELUCTANCE
ON ON BEHALF OF SOME OF THE
WITNESSES.
THEY HAVE THE THE VICTIM HAS
ALREADY BEEN FOR PROVIDED SOME
PROTECTION THEY'RE NOT --
JEOPARDIZED OR PENALIZED -- BY
THIS -- ADDITIONAL TIME PERIOD
I'M GONNA SUPPORT THE BILL BUT
I'D LIKE TO SUGGEST THAT THE
THAT THIS IS A QUESTION THAT
SHOULD BE LOOKED AT FURTHER.
AND WHEN YOU SAY THAT THE THAT
THE ALLEGED VICTIM IS THEN
REMOVED FROM THE SITUATION
ACTUALLY.
THERE REMOVED FROM BUT BECAUSE
THE THE PERSON THE PERPETRATOR
HAS BEEN REMOVED GOOD I WAS
COVER TRAINING MAKES THE MOVE NO
THEY MOVED THE PERPETRATOR SO
THE THE VICTIM IS.
STILL DOING.
HER HIS OR HER JOB THEY'RE NOT
AFFECTED BY IT ALL UP THE ONLY
PERSON AFFECT TO BE THE THANK
YOU AND I APPRECIATE THAT
BECAUSE SAID DID RAISE A RED
FLAG FOR ME.
BUT I I WOULD JUST ASK THAT IF
WE REALLY ARE SERIOUS ABOUT THAT
WHOLE ISSUE WE TRY TO EXPEDITE --
THE TIME FRAME FOR THAT AS WELL
I SUPPORT THIS BUT I THINK THAT
IT'S A CARVE OUT THAT THERE
MIGHT BE.
RECONSIDERED THANK YOU AND I'M
HONORED ACTION -- WE WILL HAVE A
MOTION WE HAVE AS OTHERS IN
SUPPORT.
I DON'T BELIEVE WE'VE ASKED FOR
THAT AS OF YET IS THERE ANYONE
HERE IN OPPOSITION.
THE NO ONE NOW BRING IT BACKTO
THE COMMITTEE FOR CONVERSATION
DISCUSSION.
WE HAVE NOW WE DO HAVE A PER
PROPOSED MOTION WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AYE VOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
HAVE A MOTION FROM SENATOR
JACKSON'S.
IN THIS IS -- DO PASS AS AMENDED --
AND I REALLY APPRECIATE THE THE
CONVERSATION WE WERE ABLE TO
COME TO AN AGREEMENT ON THAT
THURMOND THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
YOU PASSED -- TO AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS THANK YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL SENATOR HILL AYE
HILL AYE MORRELL.
WE'RE ALONE JACKSON JAX I
MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE.
SO WE HAVE -- THREE EAT THREE
VOTES THAT BILL WILL BE OUT TO
THE WILL HOLD THE ROLLOVER FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY
VERY MUCH [inaudible]
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SANTIAGO.
YOU STILL THERE THANK YOU MOVING
TO ITEM NUMBER [inaudible]
SIX EIGHTY EIGHT NINETY FOUR
GOOD MORNING
.
GOOD MORNING THE HUMAN LEAGUE
RECEIVE WHEN YOU'RE READY THANK
YOU YES -- THINK MISS CHURN
CENTERS US PRETTY SIMPLE BILL AB
I EIGHT NINETY FOUR WOULD
INCREASE THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
EXEMPTS ADDITIONS -- WITHIN THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
SIMPLY FROM POINT TO A TO POINT
7% OF THEIR CURRENT STAFF MOST A
CONSTITUTIONAL OFFICERS HAD
BETWEEN ONE OR 2%.
OUR DUTY WITH AN EXISTING BUDGET
AN EXISTING POSITIONS ALSO IT
SHOULD BE NO CHANGE THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
AND HAVE A REPRESENT OF THE AG
HERE TODAY WE'RE GOOD THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING [inaudible]
YEAH.
GOOD MORNING US RIGHT AT THE
PAGE WITH THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
OFFICE I'M JUST WANTED TO MAKE A
QUICK STATEMENT AND SAY THAT I
80% ROSE -- PROUD TO SPONSOR AB
EIGHT NINE FOUR IN THE EX
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SANTIAGO FOR
AUTHORING THIS BILL -- WITH THIS
BILL DOES IS IT WOULD ENSURE
THAT THE ATTORNEY GENERAL CAN
MAINTAIN A STRONG ROBUST
EXECUTIVE TEAM AND OPERATIONS
THAT CAN.
ESSENTIALLY TACKLE THE DIVERSE
RESPONSIBILITIES -- OF OUR
STATES -- CHIEF LAW ENFORCEMENT.
AND LEGAL AGENCY.
THANK YOU HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
YOU VERY MUCH IS THERE ANYONE
HERE IN SUPPORT.
ANYONE HERE IN OPPOSITION.
WELL THANK YOU A AND I
APPRECIATE THE THE CONVERSATIONS
THAT I DID TALK WITH THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL YESTERDAY WE
HAD A LONG CONVERSATION BECAUSE
I WAS KIND OF UNDER A DIFFERENT
IMPRESSION AS TO WHAT THESE
POSITIONS WOULD BE USED FOR WHAT
THAT WHAT THEY WOULD.
DO -- MORE OF AN ADVOCACY ROLE
RATHER THAN SOMETHING THAT --
BUT I I HAVE AFTER OUR
CONVERSATION AND AND CERTAINLY
YOUR TESTIMONY THIS MORNING THAT
THE LEGISLATIVE THE LEADERSHIP
TEAM.
HE SHOULD BE ABLE TO FILL THAT
OUT IN A WAY THAT WILL SUPPORT
HIM AND DO IT IN A IN THE MOST
EXPEDITIOUS WAY.
AND BEING ABLE TO GET THE BEST
PEOPLE POSSIBLE FORD SO I
CERTAINLY SUPPORT THE BILL AT
THIS POINT SO -- THANK YOU OF IS
THERE A MOTION TO WE HAVE A
MOTION FROM SENATOR MITCHELL
THANK YOU WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE WITH.
A START LAST NIGHT OF THE
OFFENDERS AND STRUCTURE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THAT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR HELP AYE
HILL AYE WORLD [inaudible]
JACKSON.
MITCHELL FIVE MAJOR AYE PAN.
THE BILL HAS TO VOTE TO HOLD THE
ROLE OKAY AFTER MEMBERS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FLORA.
SEE YOU IN THE BACK WE'RE MOVING
TO ITEM NUMBER.
TEN AB [inaudible] TWELVE NINETY
NINE FIFTY WAS A SOME WAS IT
SOMETHING I SAID.
I NINE FRANK IS ALWAYS A
CHALLENGE.
GOOD MORNING ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FLOORS NICE TO SEE YOU ITEM
NUMBER TEN EIGHTY BE TWELVE
NINETY NINE PLEASE PROCEED THANK
YOU CHAIR MEMBERS.
CHAIR.
AB TWELVE NINETY NINE IT SURE IS
A VOLUNTEER FIREFIGHTERS ARE
REIMBURSED TO PAY THAT THERE DO
FROM PROVIDING EMERGENCY
SERVICES THROUGH THE MUTUAL AID
A FIRE SYSTEM.
AGREEMENTS AND LARGE SCALE
INCIDENTS LIKELY LAKE COUNTY AND
CAMPFIRES FEDERAL STATE
GOVERNMENT PROVIDE REIMBURSEMENT
FOR FIRE DEPARTMENTS
PARTICIPATING IN A MUTUAL AID
AGREEMENTS.
IN ORDER TO REIMBURSE VOLUNTEER
FIREFIGHTERS FOR THEIR WORK.
IF FULL REIMBURSEMENT IS NOT
PASSED THROUGH THESE FLKS MAY
BE DISCOURAGED FROM
PARTICIPATING IN VOLUNTEER
PROGRAMS. TWELVE EIGHTY NINE
WILL FOSTER MUCH NEED AN
ENVIRONMENT WHERE FIREFIGHTER
VOLUNTEER FIREFIGHTERS ARE
PRECEDED A COMPENSATED FOR THEIR
HARD WORK PRETENDING CALIFORNIA
WILDFIRES.
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
AFRICA VARGAS FROM THE CALPERS
STATE ASSOCIATION Q. VERY MUCH
PLEASE PROCEED THANK CHAIRMAN --
AFTERWARDS TO SEE IS A FAKE.
YOU RUN LEGISLATION AND WE'VE.
BEEN VERY SUPPORTIVE OF YOUR
LEGISLATION APPRECIATE THE WORK
YOU'VE DONE ON ON A VOLUNTEER
FIREFIGHTER COMMUNITY.
THIS WILL HELP INSURE THAT THOSE
VOLUNTEERS WHO ARE VOLUNTEERS IN
THE COMMUNITY BUT ARE VIEWED AS
A RESOURCE STATEWIDE FOR MANY OF
THESE LARGE SCALE INCIDENTS THAT
WE'RE HAVING ALL TOO OFTEN --
CONTINUE TO BE A RESOURCE AND
THAT THEY GET THE MONEY THAT
THEY SIGNED UP.
FOR I THANK YOU OTHERS IN
SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANYONE HERE IN
OPPOSITION.
GOOD BRING YOU BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE AND NOT AND YOU'VE HAD
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE WITH THIS
OBVIOUSLY ABSOLUTELY THE
SOMETHING DONE SINCE -- TWO
THOUSAND IN A LOT OF DIFFERENT
WAYS SO I WORKED AS A VOLUNTEER
IS CERTAINLY WITH THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AS WELL AND WILDFIRES
SO.
WE WORK ON A DAILY BASIS WITH
OUR VOLUNTEER ON FRIENDS AND
WHEN THEY'RE THEY'RE ON A MUTUAL
AID AND AN INITIAL RESPONSE IT'S
INCREDIBLY VALUABLE.
AND THE ONLY WAY THAT WE GET
THESE FOLKS TO TO COME AND JOIN
US AS WE MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
REIMBURSING THE PROPERLY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND I'LL TAKE THAT AS A CLOSE
AND WE WILL AS SOON AS WE CAN
ESTABLISH A AT LEAST A AB AFFECT
I COULD.
MAKE THE MOST WELL WILL DO THE
MOTION WHEN WE GET SOME PEOPLE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATED
THANK CHAIRMAN MANY SOMEONE
ELSE'S THANK YOU.
I COULD HAVE MADE.
WICKS DOT ORG ALAS [inaudible]
WE WILL [inaudible]
HAVE A MINOR RECESS UNTIL WE
HAVE.
SOME MEMBERS HERE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU
THE TWO TWENTY SO FAR SO LET'S
WE CAN.
WE WILL DO THAT WE'RE MOVING NOW
TO ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN AB
THIRTEEN FIFTY THREE WELCOME TO
OUR COMMITTEE [inaudible]
MORNING.
COMMITTEE HAVE STAFF COLLEAGUES
I WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
TODAY.
CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES ARE
CRITICAL TO OUR PUBLIC SCHOOL
SYSTEM BY PROVIDING HEALTH
NUTRITION ACADEMIC SUPPORTS TO
STUDENTS ALTHOUGH CLASSIFIED
WORK IS COMPLETED BY THE SAME
STANDARD REGARDLESS OF WHETHER A
DISTRICT IS MERIT DISTRICT OR
NON MERIT DISTRICT.
CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES IN A NON
MERIT DISTRICT HAVE A LONGER
PROBATIONARY PERIOD OF ONE YEAR
WHERE'S THE MERIT DISTRICT
ALLOWS FOR A SIX MONTH
PROBATIONARY PERIOD.
AB THIRTEEN FIFTY THROUGH THREE
WILL BRING CONFORMITY AND
CLARITY FOR K. THROUGH TWELVE
CLASSIFIED STAFF BY ALLOWING.
FOR CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES IN NON
MERIT DISTRICTS TOOBTAIN
PERMANENT STATUS NO LATER THAN
SIX MONTHS.
MANY NON MERIT DISTRICTS ALREADY
CONFORM TO THE MERIT DISTRICT
TIME LIMITS.
DUE TO COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
AGREEMENTS ALIGNING BOTH OF
THESE COULD ADVISE SIMPLIFIES
THE PROCESS.
I WANT TO THANK OUR SPONSORS THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS AND I WILL LET MY
WITNESS SELF INTRODUCED NEVER
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
FOR WHEN FOLKS SHOW UP.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IF WE WILL
DO THAT.
MORE MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE CHRISTY
DHAMMA BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS --
PROUDLY SUPPORT SUPPORT OF
PROUDLY REPRESENTING A
CALIFORNIA'S TEACHERS AND ALSO
OF HUGE SEGMENT SEGMENT OF OUR
POPULATION ARE CLASSIFIED
SERVICE.
AS ARE OTHERS MENTION THIS BILL
IS ABOUT FAIRNESS AND EQUITY.
A CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES SUFFER
UNDER PRACTICES WHERE THEY FIND
THEMSELVES YEAR OVER YEAR AND
TEMPORARY STATUS OFTEN.
UNRELATED TO THEIR WORK
PERFORMANCE WE THINK PARITY IN A
PUSH PROBATIONARY PERIOD IS --
OFFERS THE STABILITY AND
SECURITY THAT THESE EMPLOYEES.
CAN RELY ON THEY ARE THE LOWEST
PAID EMPLOYEES IN THE PUBLIC
SECTOR.
AND BUT IT'S SERVING A VERY
IMPORTANT SIGNIFICANT ROLE IN
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS LIVES AND SO
FOR THOSE REASONS WE URGE YOUR
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE.
VERY GOOD THANK YOUS WILL OTHERS
IN SUPPORT.
ANYONE HERE IN OPPOSITION.
PLEASE COME FORWARD THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING TURN MEMBERS DEREK
LIMITS ON BEHALF OF THE SCHOOL
EMPLOYERS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA REGRETTABLY WE MUST
OPPOSE THE BILL -- WE EXPLAIN IN
OUR LETTER THE REASONS THAT SIX
MONTHS MAY BE INSUFFICIENT TO
PROVIDE AN ADEQUATE REVIEW OF
THE EMPLOYEES IN THE WAYS THAT
IT MAY ADVERSELY AFFECT.
EMPLOYEES AS WELL AS THE
EMPLOYERS IN THOSE SITUATIONS
THAT HAVE TO COME TO A
RELATIVELY QUICKER DETERMINATION --
BUT THE POINT THAT I WANT TO
MAKE HERE AT THE DIS TODAY.
IS THAT IF THE INTENT OF THE
BILLS TO CLARIFY -- FOR
EMPLOYEES WHETHER THEY ARE SIX
MONTHS ARE SUBJECT TO A TWELVE
MONTH PROBATIONARY PERIOD -- AS
THE AUTHOR AND SPONSOR HAVE
STATED N THE PAST.
THAT CHANGING EVERYBODY FROM
TWELVE TO SIX DOES SEEM LIKE
RATHER STRONG MEDICINE.
MOST OF THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS
ACROSS THE STATE A LIKE TO BE
TWELVE MONTHS SOME NEGOTIATE
DOWN TO SIX MONTHS AND THAT
SEEMS APPROPRIATE SUBJECT
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING ONE
DISTRICT THAT I SPOKE TO RATHER
RECENTLY FROM NEVADA COUNTY IS A
SMALL SCHOOL DISTRICT.
AND THEY AND THEIR LOCAL UNION
BOTH AGREED WE'RE ON SIX MONTHS
WE WANT TO MOVE UP TO TWELVE
BECAUSE WE THINK THAT'S GONNA BE
FAIR FOR THE EMPLOYEES AND OFFER
THE EMPLOYER BETTER CHANCE TO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL TRAINING. TO
EMPLOYEES THAT NEED IT SO.
THERE DOESN'T SEEM TO BE A
PROBLEM IN OUR MIND WITH THE
LOCAL OPTION TO DO THAT AND
SWITCHING EVERYBODY OVER RATHER
THAN SIMPLY PROVIDING MORE
INFORMATION FOR EXAMPLE DURING
THE EMPLOYEE ORIENTATION WHICH
IS REQUIRED NOW -- WOULD SEEM
LIKE AN APPROPRIATE SOLUTION IF
WE WANT TO CLARIFY FOR WORKERS
WHAT THEIR RIGHTS ARE.
IN THEIR LOCAL COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AGREEMENT THANK YOU
FOR YOUR THANK YOU -- AIRBAG
WITH THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
BOARDS ASSOCIATION OUT WE DON'T
HAVE AN ISSUE WHETHER SIX MONTHS
OR TWELVE MONTHS AS OUR
CONVERSATIONS WE BELIEVE SHOULD
BE AT THE LOCAL LEVEL -- WHAT I
DO WANNA AND WE REFERENCE IN OUR
LETTER IS THAT THERE IS A?
A SIGNIFICANT DIFFERENCE IN
MERIT NOT MERIT DISTRICTS -- AYE
AYE IF YOU LOOK AT THESE ARE THE
STATUTES.
COVERING MERIT SCHOOL DISTRICTS
IT'S TWENTY FIVE PAGES LONG IT
CREATES THE INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
SUPPORTS THE REASON WHY YOU GO
TO SIX MONTHS THAT DOESN'T EXIST
IN A NON MERS SCHOOL DISTRICT
FOR EXAMPLE HE WOULD HAVE TO
HAVE A PERSONAL COMMISSION THAT
STRICTLY FOCUSED ON OVERSEEING
EVALUATING TESTING -- MERITS
THAT COST FIVE EMPLOYEES AT AND
YOU GO THROUGH A WITTY --
WIGGLING OUT OF QUALIFIED
APPLICANTS IN ADVANCE OF EVEN
HIRING SO YOU'VE ALREADY KIND OF
TAKING CARE OF SOME OF THE RISK
IN ADVANCE OF EVEN HIRING.
WHEN AT SIX MONTHS AND
CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES IT'S
IMPORTANT TO KNOW THAT THEY'RE
NOT LIKE TYPICAL TEACHERS AT
START IN AUGUST AND WORK THROUGH
A WHOLE CALENDAR SCHOOL YEAR?
THEY MAY START IN MAY THEY MIGHT
WORK MAY AND JUNE AND NOT WORK
JULY AUGUST AND SEPTEMBER THAT
SIX MONTHS START FROM THE DATE
THE THING SO YOU'RE NOT GONNA
HAVE A WINDOW OF OPPORTUNITY TO
REALLY UNDERSTAND AND EVALUATE
EMPLOYEE.
SO THAT SIX MONTHS YOU HAVE TO
MAKE A DETERMINATION BASED ON
THE FIRST TWO MONTHS OF THEIR
EMPLOYMENT.
YOU HAVE TO MAKE A DECISION IS A
SIMPLE WAY WORTH KEEPING ON OR
NOT.
AND I THINK A SCHOOL DISTRICT
RATHER THAN GOING THROUGH THE IT
LABOR S. -- DISMISSAL PROCESS
PROBABLY UP TO MAYBE DISMISSED
THAT PERSON IF THEY DIDN'T SHOW
IMMEDIATE -- GRASP OF THE
ASSIGNMENT I DON'T KNOW THAT'S
FAIRLY ANYBODY I'M NOT SURE IT'S
FAIR TO SCHOOL DISTRICT THAT'S
BEEN RE HIGHER AND GO THROUGH
THE PROCESS.
OR IS THAT A FAIR TO THE
EMPLOYEE THEY THINK IF THEY WERE
GIVEN AN OPPORTUNITY.
SO WE JUST THINK THAT THE COUNTY
YOUR CYCLE OF A SCHOOL DISTRICT
IS NOT A TYPICAL TWELVE MONTH
WORK ENVIRONMENT.
BECAUSE YOU HAVE BASICALLY IN
EIGHT MONTHS NINE MONTHS SCHOOL
YEAR.
AND SO I THINK THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT NEEDS BEGIN PRODUCT
INCINERATION COUPLED WITH THE
IDEA THAT.
THERE ARE OTHER INFRASTRUCTURE
ELEMENTS THAT MAKE SIX MONTHS
WORK FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT
HAVE CHOSE TO GO THAT PATH I
USED TO WORK FOR LOS ANGELES
UNIFIED THEY HAVE IN THEIR
SCHOOL DISTRICT.
BUT THERE IS A SYSTEMATIC
PROCESS TO WEED OUT GOOD
APPLICANTS AND APPLICANTS BEFORE
THEY'RE EVEN HIRED SO YOU KNOW
YOU'RE GETTING THE BEST POSSIBLE
OFFICE CAN'T.
THAT DOESN'T EXIST WITHIN A NON
MERIT SCHOOL BASIS AND TO
SUGGEST THAT SHE SHOULD HAVE
JUST SIX MONTHS AND TWELVE
MONTHS WITHOUT THE EXTRA
INFRASTRUCTURE.
I THINK THIS DOES MORE HARM THAN
GOOD. FOR THAT WE WOULD OPPOSE.
OTHERS POSITION YES THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND CENTER MORALE A
JEFF BARKER REPRESENTING THE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT
OF SCHOOLS AND I WOULD SIMPLY
ASSOCIATE MYSELF WITH THE
COMMENTS THAT MY COLLEAGUES HAVE
MADE IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MORE PRESSING ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS
WERE ALSO IN OPPOSITION HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT
HAVE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD MORNING SERRA BUT JUST WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
SCHOOL BUSINESS OFFICIALS ALSO
IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
WAIT FOR JUST ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF GREAT
POWERS THAT THIRTIES WE'D ALSO
LIKE TO RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT
STUDENTS SAFE.
FIRST PRIORITY AND HAVING JUST
SIX MONTHS TO ASSESS THE
CALIBRATING INDIVIDUAL WHO IS --
AROUND THESE CHILDREN IS NOT
ENOUGH TIME.
THANK YOU.
SHALL CAST OF SERVICE EMPLOYEES
INTERNATIONAL IN SORRY I'M OUT
OF ORDER IT WAS OUT OF THE ROOM
LOOKING UPWARD SUPPORT THE BILL.
WE ACTUALLY -- BELIEVE IT SIX
MONTHS IS ADEQUATE TIME TO
DETERMINE WHETHER A PERSON IS
QUALIFIED.
UNLIKE BUT THE PREVIOUS --
SPEAKER JUST SAID EMPLOYEES ARE
SCREENED UPON HIRING ARE THEY
SAFE THEY HAVE CRIMINAL
BACKGROUND CHECKS THEY HAD TO
TAKE A COMPETENCY TEST WE THINK
SIX MONTHS IS PLENTY OF TIME TO
DETERMINE WHETHER SOMEONE IS
ACTUALLY QUALIFIED TO DO THE JOB.
WESLEY I DON'T YOU THINK YOU.
SO IT'S REALLY GONNA HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
ALSO APOLOGIES FOR BEING OUT OF
ORDER WHERE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE AND THE PARDEE
QUESTION NO QUESTION SAYS IT AYE
AYE I THINK THE OPPOSITION MAKES
A COUPLE OF GOOD POINTS I BE I
DON'T KNOW IF IT.
DOESN'T TIP THE SCALE FOR ME BUT
I DO THINK THAT THERE MAY BE
SOME.
TRUMP STAFF THAT MADE.
NOT BE RETAINED BECAUSE OF THE
SIX MONTHS VERSUS AN OPPORTUNITY
TO SEE IF THEY DO HAVE.
WHAT'S LEFT -- OR IF THEY HAVE
THE ABILITY AFTER THAT PERIOD OF
TIME AND THEY MAY JUST LET THEM
GO TO NOT TAKE THE CHANCE BUT
I'M ASSUMING AND JUST AS WAS
MENTIONED.
THE VETTING THE GOES INTO
ESPECIALLY FOR SOMEONE IN THAT
CATEGORY IS.
IS STRONG AND AND OBVIOUSLY --
THINK COMPREHENSIVE ENOUGH TO
MAKE IT WORK SO IDEA.
OF WE I WILL MOVE THE BILL.
AND WE WILL OF HAVE THE VOTE.
SORRY.
I'LL MOVE THE BILL AND THIS IS
TO DO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
FLOOR.
SO OF PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
SENATOR HILL AYE HILL AYE
MORRELL.
WORLDNOW JACKSON.
MITCHELL PAN.
THE WHOLE THE WHOLE THE ROLLOVER
FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH
[inaudible]
THANKS
YEAH.
THAT'S TWO WITH.
AN OBSESSION OUR PEOPLE
[inaudible]
THIS BILL. FOR THE MACHINE.
IT.
SAYS HERE.
SO BEFORE.
OKAY SO WE'RE WITH SINCERITY WE
HAVE A WEEK [inaudible]
THE WHOLE.
ON THE ON THE IF YOU WISH
.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER O'DONNELL WELCOME.
FOURTEEN AB.
SIXTEEN THIRTEEN APPRECIATE YOU.
THANKS CREATION ON BEING HERE
FOR ME I KNOW THIS.
IS THE BEST BUT REALLY AM NOT
SHUTTING IT DOWN -- I WOULD HAVE
TO THREATEN A DIFFERENT WOULDN'T
DO NOT WOULD NEVER DO IT.
PLEASE PROCEED I THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
AB SIXTEEN THIRTEEN DIVIDES
PUBLIC WORKS TO INCLUDE CHARTER
SCHOOL FACILITY PROJECTS THAT
RECEIVE FUNDING THROUGH CONDUIT
REVENUE BONDS.
THIS WOULD ENSURE THAT
INDIVIDUALS WHO WORK ON THESE
PROJECTS RECEIVE PREVAILING WAGE
AND ALLOW THEM TO BENEFIT.
FROM A FRIENDSHIP PROGRAMS WHICH
WE KNOW ARE VERY VALUABLE.
CONDUIT REVENUE BOND IS
FINANCING COORDINATED BY A NON
PROFIT OR PUBLIC ENTITY SUCH AS
A CALIFORNIA SCHOOL FINANCE
AUTHORITY UNDER THE TREASURER'S
OFFICE.
THE STATE LOSES REVENUE ON THESE
BONDS AS INVESTORS DO NOT PAY
TAXES.
INTERN THE BORROWER BENEFITS BY
RECEIVING LOWER INTEREST RATES.
UNDER EXISTING LAW CHARTER
SCHOOL FACILITIES THAT ARE
FUNDED BY STATE EDUCATION BONDS
ARE REQUIRED TO COMPLY WITH THE
PREVAILING WAGE AND HIGHER
CONSTRUCTION STANDARDS UNDER THE
FIELD ACT.
PROJECTS THAT ARE FUNDED THROUGH
CONDO BONDS HOWEVER DO NOT HAVE
TO PAY PREVAILING WAGE WE MUST
ENSURE THAT THAT THE THAT THOSE
WORKING ON THE STATE SUBSIDIZED
PROJECTS ARE SKILLED AND
QUALIFIED.
THIS IS A POLICY THAT KEEPS
GIVING A FIRM BELIEVER IN THIS
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS MIDDLE
pIMPACT ON ECONOMY IT'S THE
POLICY.
IT KEEPS GIVING.
HERE IN SUPPORT IS -- JEREMY --
FROM THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION -- COUNCIL TRAITS.
THANK YOU FOR CHAIR MORNING
MEMBERS OF COMMITTEE JEREMY
SMITH YOUR BEHALF OF THE SERVICE
REP ANSWERS LAST NAME
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL OF
MINISTERS YEAH.
YES WE KNOW THAT LEGEND COMING
SAYS ARE -- I WOULD HAVE BEEN A
PROBLEM THAT WOULD ONLY.
WE ARE HERE -- THE PROUD
SPONSORS OF THIS LEGISLATION.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER O'DONNELL LAID
OUT HOW CONDUIT REVENUE
FINANCING WORKS.
I WILL GO INTO THAT ANYMORE I
WILL WILL SIMPLY SAY THAT OF
REQUIRING THE PREVAILING WAGE ON
THESE PROJECTS.
LEADS TO AYE THE USE OF A HIGHLY
MORE HIGHLY SKILLED AND TRAINED
WORKFORCE BECAUSE CONTRACTORS TO
BID ON THESE PROJECTS.
ARE GOING TO UTILIZE THAT TYPE
OF COURSE THIS LEADS TO BETTER
BUILT SCHOOLS SAFER SCHOOLS
SCHOOLS BILL ON TIME ON BUDGET --
AND THE COST BENEFIT ANALYSIS
GOES INTO PAYING THE PREVAILING
WAGE SHOULD FACTOR INTO THE FAX
THAT -- THAT LEAD HIGHLY SKILLED
WORKERS LEAD TO BETTER PROJECTS
SO WERE AND STRONG SUPPORT THIS
BILL -- DRIVE OF THANK YOU
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE ANY BERNACCHI
ON BEHALF OF THE NATIONAL
ELECTRICAL CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION.
THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE
CONFERENCE OF THE PLUMBING
HEATING PIPING INDUSTRY.
UNITED CONTRACTORS THE WESTERN
WALL CEILING ALLIANCE.
AND THE THAT NO THE CALIFORNIA
ALLIED TRADES -- IN STRONG
SUPPORT THE MEASURE AND WE WANT
THINK THE AUTHOR FOR PUSHING
THIS FORWARD THANK YOU.
SEPTEMBER HERE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU -- OTHERS
IN SUPPORT.
THOSE IN OPPOSITION PLEASE COME
[inaudible]
FOR MORNING.
THIS CHAIR MEMBERS JOHN WINGER
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CHARTER SCHOOLS ASSOCIATION WE
ARE IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL --
I THINK ONE OF THE ONE OF THE
MOST.
CHALLENGING THINGS THE CHARTER
SCHOOLS HAVE CONTINUOUSLY IS
ACCESS TO ADEQUATE FACILITIES.
AND THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT --
FUNDING MECHANISM FOR US -- TO
ACCESS THESE ADEQUATE FACILITIES
I THINK -- THE CONSEQUENCE OF OF
THIS BILL IS THAT IT'S GOING TO
INCREASE COSTS -- AND ULTIMATELY
LEADER CHARTER SCHOOLS TO NOT
USE THE CONDO.
REVENUE BOND FINANCING SYSTEM
ANYMORE AND MOVED TO THE PRIVATE
MARKET -- AND IF THEY DO NEED TO
INCREASE THEIR COSTS IS GOING TO
COME OUT OF THEIR GENERAL OB --
OPERATING BUDGET WHICH IS
DIRECTLY OUT OF THE CLASSROOM
AND OUT OF OUR TEACHERS HANDS --
I THINK IF WE'RE GOING TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION ABOUT PREVAILING
WAGE AND AND CHARTER SCHOOL --
CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS THAT IT
SHOULD BE A BROADER CONVERSATION --
TO WHERE WE CAN INCREASE ACCESS
A LOT OF OUR SCHOOLS HAVE A LOT
OF DIFFICULTY ACCESSING LOCAL
BONDS -- AND DON'T HAVE THE
EXPERTISE TO ACCESS STATE BONDS
I THINK IF WE CAN HAVE A BROADER
CONVERSATION ABOUT ACCESS TO
THOSE TO THOSE FUNDS THAN --
WE'RE HAPPY TO HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION BUT THIS BILL
APPLYING THIS TO A CONDO REVENUE
BOND FINANCING MECHANISM THAT IS
A VERY -- THERE IS A A VERY
UNIQUE AND EASIER WAY TO LOWER
OUR INTEREST RATES AND INCREASE
OUR ACCESS TO ADEQUATE
FACILITIES I THINK IS A GOOD
THING AND SO WE ARE OPPOSE THE
BILL.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
NO ONE BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE.
I I THINK IT'S A IT'S A IT'S OF
GREAT BUILDS FAIR.
OF ME WE DO USE THIS RIGHT NOW.
FOR ACUTE CARE HOSPITALS AND
ELSEWHERE WHERE THERE ARE IS
CONDUIT FINANCING.
THAT THE PREVAILING WAGE WOULD
APPLY AND I THINK IT'S ONLY FAIR
THAT WE DO IN THIS CASE I THINK
IT.
TOO WONDERFUL BUT WE DO HAVE A
MOTION FROM SENATOR JACKSON
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I JUST
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR IT'S ONLY
FAIR BILL IT'S GOOD FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ECONOMY I ASK FOR AND
I'VE. FOR THOSE APPRENTICES AND
KNOW THAT ARE IMPORTANT TO YOU.
VERY GOOD WE DO HAVE THE MOTION
FROM CENTER JACKSON DO BEST
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE -- NO
THAT'S NOT THE DOES YOUR
APPROPRIATIONS SORRY PLEASE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL CENTER
HEALTH HI.
I'M MORAL.
NO.
WORLDNOW JACKSON AYE JACKSON AYE
MITCHELL.
PAN HI CAN I IT DOES HAVE ENOUGH
VOTE WILL HOLD A ROLL OVER FOR
THE AFTER MEMBERS THANK YOU
MISTER THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I WILL NOW GO -- WE HAVE A
MOTION ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
THE MOTION FROM SENATOR JACKSON
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR HILL I FEEL I'M MORRELL.
I JACKSON.
JACKSON AYE MITCHELL
[inaudible]
PAST.
FIVE ENCOUNTER HAS FOUR VOTES
WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS I WILL JUST GO
DOWN THE LIST OF THAT WORKS FOR
EVERYONE.
HOWEVER HE WE NEED TO HAVE NEED
A MOTION ON ITEM NUMBER TEN AB
TWELVE NINETY NINE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FLORA.
WE HAVE A MOTION FROM US SENATOR
PAN -- MOTION ON ITEM NUMBER
FIFTEEN AB.
EIGHTEEN ZERO FIVE WE HAVE A
MOTION FROM SENATOR PAM PLEASE
CALLTHE ROLL THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR
HILL HI HILL AYE MORRELL.
JACK MORRELL KNOWN JACKSON.
JACKSON HI MITCHELL.
PAN BY SENATOR PENN.
NINE THE BILL HAS THREE VOTES
WILL HOLD THE ROLL OVER FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS THERE AS WELL
WILL NOW START AT THE TOP.
I REMEMBER ONE AB -- FIFTY ONE
CURRENT VOTERS TO ONE PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE.
SENATOR MITCHELL.
PAN ARTS ENTERTAINMENT.
THE HISTORY BOOKS WE WILL HOLD
WILL OPEN FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS --
WE HAVE.
NOW ITEM NUMBER SIX AB.
EIGHT NINE FOUR A PLEASE CALL
THE OTHER MEMBERS.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR MORALE
[inaudible]
NOW MORRELL NO.
JACKSON HI [inaudible]
HI PAM.
BUT WHEN.
I AM SICK. FOR THE ONE THE BILL
HAS FOUR VOTE SHOULD AND IT IS
OUT.
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB TEN OH
SEVEN PLEASE GO YES A MEMBER.
SENATOR PAT THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR PAM.
SENATOR PAN AYE.
THE BILL HAS FOR VOTE IT IS OUT.
MOVING TO ITEM NUMBER. NINE A.
B. TEN TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
THE MOTION IS. TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO ENERGY [inaudible]
SENATOR PAM.
SENATOR PAN HI.
THE BILL HAS FOUR VOTES AND IT
IS UP.
ITEM NMBER ELEVEN A. B.
THIRTEEN FIFTY THREE PLEASE CALL
YESTERDAY.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
SENATOR JACKSON'S.
JACKSON AYE MITCHELL
[inaudible]
SENATOR PAN.
THE BILL HAS THREE VOTES WILL
HOLD THE THE ROLE OPEN FOR THE
ABSENT NUMBER.
AND I THINK EVERYONE HERE HAS
VOTED.
ITEM TWELVE I WAS PULLED.
NOW THERE'S A VERY GOOD THANK
YOU ALL VERY MUCH [inaudible]
THIS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
BECAUSE YOU MAY HAVE A FIVE ZERO
THE AT LEAST.
THOSE.
PENSION [inaudible] TWENTY
TWENTY I CAN EASILY.
OKAY.
THANKS LAST [inaudible]
YEAH.
I THINK I'M AS WE REALLY SAW
WHAT I THINK
[inaudible]
IT.
WELCOME BACK THANK YOU NOW WITH
THE TREE HERE WE WILL START WITH
ITEM NUMBER ONE AB.
FIFTY ONE THIS CALL THE AFTER
MEMBER.
I'M SORRY I WOULD HEAR.
FOR FIFTY ONE I MADE THE MOTION.
DID YOU MAKE SURE.
FIVE AB FIFTY ONE ARE YOU DON'T
HAVE FOR YOU.
I DON'T ACCEPT OKAY THE ONLY
LOOKS VOCAL MEMBER I HAD THE
WHOLE CONVERSATION ABOUT BEING
ADDED.
WHEN YOU LEFT YOU DID YOU WERE
OUTSIDE [inaudible]
ALL [inaudible]
YOU DID.
READY THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
YOU CAN JUST WAIT. TO THE BEST A
JUDICIARY OF IF OKAY SENATOR
MITCHELL I MITCHELL.
FIVE THE BILL HAS FOR VOTE IT IS
OUT -- WILL GO TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR -- YES REMEMBER.
SENATOR MITCHELL HI.
THE CONSENT CALENDAR HAS FIVE
VOTES IT IS OUT.
THANK YOU WILL NOW MOVE TO ITEM
NUMBER. TEN AB TWELVE NINETY
NINE ASSEMBLYMEMBER FLORA PLEASE
CALL THE AFTERMATH MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR
MITCHELL.
ARE A. B. THIRTEEN FIFTY THREE
THE COACH THREE TWO ONE PLEASE
CALL THE AFTER MEMBER THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED SENATOR
MITCHELL HI MITCHELL I FOR ONE
THAT FEEL IS OUT.
AND ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN AB
SIXTEEN THIRTEEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER O'DONNELL PLEASE
CALL AFTER MEMBER.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR MITCHELL
HI MITCHELL I FOR ONE AND THAT
THE BILL IS OUT.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
[inaudible]
AND I'M SORRY WE HAVE THE
COMMITTEE BILL OF A. B. EIGHTEEN
OH FIVE ITEM NUMBER.
FIFTEEN MITCHELL OPTION OKAY TO
PASS TO PREPARATIONS MITCHELL
WHO HAS FOUR ONE FOUR VOTE TO IT
IS OUT OF THIS HEARING IS
ADJOURNED THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU SO MUCH